Naisu!
HoG
Wird mal wieder Zeit hier, die Twitch Settings
sind auch jedes Mal irgendwie anders.
Versucht gerade die Emotes zu finden,
aber keine Chance, Alter.
Settings, Partner, da sind die Emotes
bestimmt. Nee.
Alter, wo sind die Emotes hin? Und was will Twitch von mir?
Ich soll ein Dark 7 Tags
Interview machen. What?
Alter.
Was? Können...
Kann... Kann nicht mal irgendwas einfach so funktionieren,
ohne dass man da offen irgendwas nicht findet und was machen muss? Moin, Max.
Was muss ich machen? Twitch sagt mir gerade auf dem zweiten Bildschirm,
Moment, Dark 7
Tags Interview soll ich machen, weil...
Please complete the Tags Information
Interview fully.
Hä?
Das hab ich doch alles schon mal gemacht.
Warum muss ich das jetzt noch mal machen?
Go to Interviews, dauert nur 5 Minuten.
Ja, ganz bestimmt dauert das nur 5 Minuten. Das dauert 5 Minuten,
wenn du 3 Stunden lang irgendwelche Dokumente gesucht hast,
wahrscheinlich.
Hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf, ey, nee, nee, nee.
Ich mach jetzt kein Tags Interview, muss ich nachher machen.
Okay, was? Twitch, Twitch, Twitch, was passiert, wenn man das
Tags Interview nicht macht?
New EU Regulations require EU...
EU... EU... Alter, ich kann aber
ausreden, ich kann aber nicht sprechen, man. EU, ich sag EU, okay?
Based Creators to complete a 5-Minute
Tags Interview. Was?
Neue EU Regulations, die EU geht mir auch
im Prinzip eigentlich nur auf den Sack mit irgendwelchen neuen Regulations.
So, nee, das mach ich jetzt nicht, da hab ich echt keinen Nerv drauf.
Danke für den Sub. Huge Subscription.
Ich hab richtig krass viel gefressen vorhin, Leute.
Massive, nachdem ich wieder ein bisschen abgenommen hab, hab ich mir gedacht,
das kann ich ja wieder zunehmen.
Ich hab mich heute Morgen auf die Waage gestellt
und ich war gar nicht drauf vorbereitet,
mich da irgendwie groß zu wiegen, ne?
Normalerweise wiege ich mich nach dem Aufstehen in Unterhose,
nur dass das irgendwie immer vergleichbar ist. Vorhin hab ich mich
gewogen, nach dem Frühstücken
mit Jogginghose und Hemd und so schon an.
Da hatte ich ganz knapp 91,2.
Also ich hab, also ohne Scheiß, Leute, das...
Gerade das Fahrradfahren hat echt nochmal viel gebracht mit Gewicht...
...Bells. Nee, nee, nee, kein Nudel mit Lachs.
Heute gab's Nudel mit Tomatensauce.
Oh, der Iron Champ ist am Start.
Den, den brauchen wir jetzt.
Ich mach mal kurz Update. Ich glaube, es hat sich einiges an
Packages getan in letzter Zeit.
Naja, Guppen.
Leute, ich hab Zeuche installiert
auf meinem Arch Linux. Ich weiß nicht mal, was...
Was ist mit Guppen?
Ach nee, Moment. Ist es GU-PNP?
Oder ist es Guppen?
Es ist wahrscheinlich eher
GU-PNP.
Also GNU.
Universal Plug and Play.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Was ist...
Guppen...
Gupen...
Object-Oriented Framework for Creating...
Ah, UPNP Device.
Ey, what the fuck?
Was hab ich alles installiert, man?
Gupen.
Okay, ich weiß nicht. Irgendwas...
Ich kann ja mal ausprobieren. Ach ja, Leute.
Ich kann heute nicht richtig tippen.
Weil...
Ah ja, es prägt, weil
Gupen ist gebraucht bei...
Gupen. Ja, ach nee.
Hahaha.
Da wär ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen, Alter.
Und ansonsten...
What?
Okay, nur, dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Ich kann Gupen nicht
deinstallieren, weil es von Gupen
gebraucht wird.
Und auch von Lib Gupen.
Okay, und was
ist das? Ich frag mich nur,
wer das installiert hat. Ich nicht.
A library to handle UPNP
IGD Port Mapping.
Alles klar.
Hahaha.
Das wär bescheid, oder?
Jetzt ist alles klar.
Also, okay.
Ich weiß, was die mir sagen wollen.
Universal Plug and Play.
Das ist diese Geschichte mit
Wir machen dynamisch Ports auf.
Im Zweifelsfall auch
nach außen. Aber...
Oder war das
Media Streaming? Ich blick grad nicht.
Ich weiß grad aus dem Kopf nicht.
Könnte auch Media Streaming
sein.
Oder war es einfach beides?
Egal, ich lass das einfach mal installiert.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich es installiert hab, aber...
Naja.
Leute, wir machen heute ein bisschen
Broggers im Stream, aber ich kann nicht richtig...
Was macht eigentlich
Twimoji?
Hat Twimoji eigentlich die neuen
Sachen? Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie es aussieht.
Twimoji wurde
zuletzt geupdated
im Januar.
Und was macht
dieser...
Okay, Unicode 15 haben sie noch
nicht geschafft.
Und was macht dieser Twimoji-Fork?
Gibt es da irgendwas
Neues? 23.
März. Na, das bringt mir jetzt auch nix.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt mal seriously.
Was für ein Emoji-Font soll ich
eigentlich benutzen unter Linux jetzt?
Hehehe.
Ja, der Titel ist
auch nicht von mir. Joho
27. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Und Artenoxeto,
danke für den Sub, Leute.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Und zwar...
Du meinst diese...
Das HTTP von Google?
Nee, groß angeschaut nicht. Ich weiß,
was es ist. Ja, aber...
Naja, noch nicht mal wirklich.
Nur, dass es diese Google-HTTP-Geschichte ist.
Ähm...
Was für ein Emoji-Font verwende ich jetzt eigentlich gescheit
unter Linux, seit
Twimoji suckt? Also ich meine, noch
geht Twimoji, ja.
Aber beispielsweise das allerwichtigste
Emoji, nämlich die
Gans,
die gibt's nicht. Aber
Noto... Oh, das ist so hässlich.
Ich mag die überhaupt nicht.
Guck mal.
Äh.
Moment, das sind nicht die richtigen.
Ich mag die Noto-Emojis überhaupt
nicht. Okay,
Linux Recommended
Emoji-Font.
Gibt's da... Gibt's da
irgendwelche
Hi-Fat-Reddit-Comments, die so
ein Jahr alt sind, ungefähr?
Tools, anytime, ja.
Joa.
Also voll
für'n Arsch eigentlich.
Ja, Twimoji
suckt halt.
Ich mag... Ich mag
Noto-Emoji nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Also ich persönlich finde Twimoji mit Abstand
den hübschesten Font. Da gibt es
bestimmt irgendwelche Twimoji-Patches.
Da gibt's doch garantiert Leute, die da
schon, auch wenn man das nicht darf,
die neuen Icons reingepatcht
haben, oder? Oder auch nicht.
Er meint, das geht ja nicht.
Das geht ja nicht. Du darfst dir die neuen Bilder
nicht mehr verwenden, weil die Bilder mittlerweile von
Twitter, seit Elon am Start
ist, dürfen die neuen Emoji-Bilder
von Twitter nicht mehr benutzt werden für
irgendwelche Fonts. Ne.
Ne, heute nicht. Ich war
gestern wieder ein bisschen Fahrrad fahren
und heute einfach nur eineinhalb Stunden so ein bisschen
durch den Wald laufen. Aber nicht rennen.
Einfach nur laufen. Man darf ja nicht
mehr.
Das ist ja das Dumme.
Die haben ja, deswegen
deswegen hebt dieser Fork
wahrscheinlich auch nicht ab.
Was ist denn das? Flemmoji.
Ein Emoji-Giftpicker.
Was man hier alles findet.
Was ist das? Flemmoji.
Advanced
Emoji-Picker for Linux,
Windows and MacOS.
Ich dachte auch GIF.
Ach so. Ach im Prinzip sowas hier,
was ich schon hab.
Nur das ist bestimmt
Elektron-based, Leute. Wollen wir wetten?
Elektron-based. Im Zweifelsfall
450 MB RAM für einen
Emoji-Picker. Und man kann
GIFs picken. Immerhin.
Ne, Dart. Flutter ist es,
Leute. Es ist nicht Elektron.
Es ist Flutter.
Flutter Desktop.
Taugt das mittlerweile?
Ne, ich mag
ohne Scheiß, der einzige Emoji-Font
den Windows-Emoji-Font
den hier, ich mag
also, ok, ich finde
der geht halbwegs.
Ich finde eigentlich, der geht.
Der ist nicht ganz so schlimm
wie die anderen. Ich mag Twimoji.
Twimoji ist der beste Emoji-Font.
Also für mich, ja.
Sehr geschmackssachemäßig.
Den alten Blob-Emoji-Font
von Android, den konnte ich mir, wenn es
unbedingt sein musste, auch noch angucken.
Also entweder Twimoji oder eben
das von Mozilla. Das ist ja, glaube ich, irgendein
Twimoji-Fork.
Die anderen, die aktuellen
Android-Emojis mag ich auch nicht.
Die Apple-Dinger gehen auch ganz gut.
Aber gibt es
den?
Ist der eigentlich Open-Source, der
Microsoft-Emoji-
Emoji-Font?
Gibt es den auf GitHub?
Fluent UI-Emoji.
Okay.
Ja, perfekt. Aber die gibt es.
Fluent Emoji.
Gibt es die als Schriftart für Linux?
Aha!
Enable Windows 11 Emojis
on Linux. Jetzt kriegen wir es erklärt, Leute,
wie es funktioniert. Okay, das funktioniert
ernsthaft. Das funktioniert
doch aber bestimmt nicht mit Color-Emojis,
oder? Leute,
ich weiß, ich lasse mich gerade etwas sidetracken,
aber irgendwie bin ich da...
Gibt es noch eine eigene Font-Config?
Gibt es den vielleicht?
Okay.
Ey, vor zwei Jahren, das ist auch alles Schrott,
man. Gefällt mir alles nicht.
Das muss ich nochmal aufschreiben,
vielleicht geht das echt, ne?
Also ganz im Ernst,
das wäre tatsächlich ein Part von
Windows, den ich ganz gerne unter Linux verwenden
würde, hier.
Die Emotes.
Die finde ich, die gehen...
Die finde ich, die gehen echt klar.
Also für mich, für mich ist eindeutig
Tweemoji, größer
Apple-Emojis,
ja, größer,
größer Windows-Emojis und der Rest gefällt mir
überhaupt nicht. Hups, da hab ich mein Fahrrad aufgemacht.
Ja,
was wollte ich denn noch sagen? Eigentlich habe ich...
Was ist denn das für... Gibt's jetzt?
ZigBee-Firmware
FiveHead.
Ach, ernsthaft?
Ja, das ist ja nice.
Moment, die konnten schon immer
ZigBee? Du kannst... Wait a minute.
Du kannst mit der gleichen Hardware,
wenn die nicht explizit ZigBee unterstützt,
auch anstatt Bluetooth-Zig...
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Das ist ja nice.
Das muss ich mir speichern.
Das muss ich mir merken.
Stream-Thema.
Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr nice,
weil von meinem sind jetzt zum allerersten
Mal die Batterien leer im Bad.
Also insofern, ich...
Das Ding...
Warum es ganz cool wäre, dass ZigBee zu haben ist,
weil ich dann keinen Relay mehr für Bluetooth brauche.
Bluetooth hat halt so eine beschissene
Reichweite. Die ist halt... Ich weiß nicht.
Drei, vier Meter oder so. Das reicht halt nicht
bis zu der Home Assistant-Kiste.
Aber
ZigBee ist natürlich viel,
viel, viel nicer.
Oh, jetzt wird's aber richtig advanced hier.
Blablabla.
Short for three seconds and enter pairing mode.
Okay.
Das ist nice. Das muss ich mir angucken.
Das machen wir aber nicht jetzt.
Das finde ich tatsächlich ganz spannend.
Das müssen wir ausprobieren.
Der Chip in den Teilen kann wohl ZigBee.
Was ich echt merkwürdig finde, dass
der ZigBee kann, weil
Xiaomi macht ja null mit ZigBee
da drin. Vielleicht hatten die das mal vor,
irgendwann zu enablen und haben gedacht,
wir machen das schon mal mit rein und
man weiß nicht.
Stimmt, was ich sagen wollte, Leute. Ich kann das gar nicht richtig
austippen, obwohl wir heute
Progress-Stream machen, weil ich habe mir
einen Finger geschnitten.
Guten Morgen. Ich wollte
einen kleinen Sensor aufmachen
und da habe ich dieses Messer
genommen. Oh, das ist ja glücklicherweise nicht richtig
scharf. Ich habe so ein
kleines, das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich auch,
iFixit
Set.
Habe ich ja vor einer Weile mal gekauft, so ein Set hier
für so Kleinkram.
Gerade für die ganzen Bits, die man sonst nicht so
braucht. Ansonsten habe ich ja nur wirklich mehr als genug
Werkzeug, aber so gerade die kleinen
die kleinen
Bits, diese Spezial-Bits
die hat man normalerweise nicht so. Guck mal
und da ist hier, das da.
Mit dem Ding habe ich mir einen Finger geschnitten, heute Morgen.
Ja.
Das ist glücklicherweise
nicht
so scharf.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich stumpf,
aber es ist scharf genug,
dass wenn du volle Pulle auf den
so drauf drückst damit und versuchst
den aufzumachen, deinen Finger
drunter hast und abrutscht
die dann halt schön den Finger schneidest
mit. Ich habe hier von
oben, so einmal quer durch den Finger
geschnitten und das
ist echt tief. Also es hat erstmal
geblutet wie Sau, bin ich ins Bad
hab Klopapier
drauf gedrückt und als es dann
ein bisschen aufgehört hat zu bluten
habe ich mal mir das angeguckt
und so ein bisschen am Finger gewackelt
und jedes Mal wenn ich am Finger gewackelt habe
dann habe ich
gesehen, wie sich das
fast so einen halben Zentimeter tief
so auseinander schiebt. Oh fuck
jetzt habe ich alles
zusammengedrückt wieder
Desinfektionsmittel
drauf getröpfelt und
Pflaster drauf.
Morgen wache ich mal auf und gucke wie es aussieht.
Ich hoffe
das ist dann morgen wieder gut.
Also ich meine das tut bestimmt noch
ein bisschen weh aber
ich hoffe das ist dann
nicht gar so sehr im Arsch alles.
Ja schon irgendwie.
Nee das kriege ich auch so hin. Ich zeige euch
gleich was wir machen
beziehungsweise was ich gebaut habe
und wir ein bisschen erweitern.
Kannst du noch alles spüren am Finger? Ja.
Also Gefühle und so ist noch da.
Ich habe ja auch nicht unten den Finger geschnitten
sondern oben den Finger. Da ist ja eh nicht so viel
so viel Fleisch. Da ist ja eigentlich fast Knochen
drunter direkt. So
Also let's go. Neu gestartet habe ich.
Wisst ihr eigentlich dass ich alle
deutschen Hoster die ich bisher
und ich muss das einschränken
alle deutschen Hoster
außer Hetzner die ich bisher
ausprobiert habe weil ich kann
ja nicht von denen sprechen die ich
noch nicht ausprobiert habe
alle deutschen Hoster außer Hetzner
die ich ausprobiert habe
beziehungsweise ausprobieren wollte
irgendwas haben was mir extrem
auf den Sack geht. Ich meine
bei Hetzner gibt es bestimmt auch die ein oder anderen Dinger
wo ich mir denke ey das könnte man ein bisschen schöner machen
aber Hetzner hat zumindest und kein
Sponsored Stream Leute. Ich habe schon eine Weile
nichts mehr gemacht mit denen aber
das ist wirklich meine persönliche Meinung dazu
Das tut er einfach für so kleinen Kram wie
lass mal ne VM bestellen
lass mal in der Server Auktion was holen und so
ist das wunderbar
und wenn man mal
das UI gerade was die
das zum Anlegen von Load Balancern
angeht das Web Interface
vergleicht mal mit Google
oder mit Azure
oder mit ok mit AWS
habe ich nicht so viel Erfahrung
dann ist das wirklich super angenehm
man kann das aber auch nicht wirklich
vergleichen weil die anderen können viel mehr
aber worauf ich raus will
ich hab gestern den Fehler gemacht
ich hab mir bei 1&1
ne ist ja nicht 1&1
doch ist 1&1 oder?
Ist Ionos nicht 1&1? Doch ich glaub schon
weil
also oh nein Postleitzahl
Leak Leute
ähm
was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen
das Azure Web Interface
generell sind die alle ein bisschen Pains Champ
was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen genau also
ich wollte mir gestern Abend
einen Server mieten und
warum dort?
weil
Hetzner explizit sagt
sie erlauben keinerlei
Block Chain
Cryptocurrency Zeug
das steht also
kannst du gucken Hetzner
ja da sagen die
ähm da steht
Crypto
ja
Following Actions sind verboten
Operating Applications
that are used to mine Cryptocurrencies
so das Ding ist
ich will keine
Cryptocurrencies minen
ähm auf der Kiste
ich würde gerne einen
Polygon Node betreiben
einen kompletten
13 Terabyte großen Polygon Node
und den will ich ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht betreiben ich will einfach nur ausprobieren wie gut das da drauf läuft
will das gar nicht
langfristig betreiben allerdings sagt
Hetzner keinerlei Cryptocurrency
bei ihnen in der Cloud
einen Polygon Node
nö ja den Support
müsste ich fragen aus 2 Gründen
also aus einem Grund müsste ich den Support fragen
wenn ich den Cloud Server haben möchte
mit SSD dran
dann muss ich meinen SSD Quota erweitern lassen
auf 15 Terabyte
allein deswegen müsste ich den Support fragen
aber wenn man auf Reddit sucht
guckt der Support sagt immer Cryptocurrency ist nicht erlaubt
was ist Polygon
das nennt das ist die
Cryptocurrency bzw. die Currencymatik
glaube ich wenn ich das richtig lese
äh wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe
und richtig gelesen habe und
also so nennt sich so nennt sich die Coin
die da drauf basiert und das ist eine
Blockchain Polygon
was für eine
ich will den Node gar nicht lange betreiben
ich wollte es nur mal ausprobieren
äh aus Gründen weil mich die
Performance da interessiert auf den Kisten
und
geht nicht so dann habe ich mir gedacht
weißt du was
gehst du zu einem anderen Anbieter
wenn Hetzner das nicht erlaubt
gehst du zu OVH
so und dann gehe ich bei OVH hin
und da ist mir eingefallen ach ne
die haben mich ja nie freigeschaltet
weil die unbedingt eine Ausweiskopie von mir haben wollen
nicht dass ich
großes Problem hätte den Provider
eine Ausweiskopie zu schicken aber
ich habe keinen Bock mein Ausweis
immer in der Weltgeschichte rum zu schicken
und wozu brauchen die mein Ausweis ich meine seriously
ich will da keinen Public Service
sonst irgendwas drauf betreiben ich will einfach nur
ein Publiches
Publichen Server haben
auf dem ich ein bisschen rumwursten kann
ja
echt die wollen wirklich
ok dann lass uns mal kurz gucken
geht das
ja das geht wirklich ohne
wann hast du das gemacht also ich wollte das
bei mir ist das noch gar nicht so lange
vor einem Jahr oder so wollte ich das machen glaube ich
jetzt nicht mehr
ah
gut vielleicht sollte ich OVH nochmal
probieren habe ich aber gestern
nicht ausprobiert weil ich mir überlegt habe
ok OVH hat mich wegen den
ok nice
und will ich nicht mehr
dann habe ich mir gedacht ok
der einzige andere deutsche Hosting Anbieter
achso bei Digital Ocean habe ich es auch mal probiert
Digital Ocean hat wie erwartet
funktioniert leider ist die
Latency der Discs bei Digital Ocean
richtig richtig langsam
also das Disc Latency bei
Digital Ocean ungefähr von
7-8 Millisekunden
und das ist extrem
passt mal auf ich zeige euch mal wie extrem
das ist
ich bin jetzt in der VM lokal ja
nur in der VM sonst nirgendwo
also noch nicht mal
auf einer echten Kiste
IO Ping
minus D minus W Punkt
Latency bei mir lokal in der VM
sind ungefähr
ja 270
Mikrosekunden
und bei Digital Ocean
ist das Storage
von der Geschwindigkeit von der Latenz her
7-8 Millisekunden
das ist richtig krass das kannst du nicht verwenden
bei Google und Microsoft
ist es übrigens ähnlich
also nur mal ich erkläre euch das
mal kurz weil das glaube ich
für einige die vielleicht auch in dem Bereich arbeiten
echt mal ganz gut ist
ganz gut ist zu wissen
warum soll ich mich Sponsor lassen
man kann doch einfach
man kann doch einfach sich das kaufen
so erinnert mich daran ich mache gleich
mit der Ionos Story weiter aber ich erzähle euch
jetzt mal was es gibt so 3
3 Faktoren
die so die
wirklich wichtig sind bei Discs
oder bei Storage
ich rede jetzt nicht von der expliziten Storage Technologie
weil gerade im Cloud Umfeld weißt du
gar nicht so sehr was da jetzt genau an der Stelle
drunter ist es gibt 3 wichtige
Sachen ok Chat wir machen
mal 5Head 5Head
es gibt was zu gewinnen
ihr kriegt einen Sub wenn ihr richtig liegt
und noch keinen habt was sind die
oder was sind aus eurer Sicht
die 3 wichtigsten
Eigenschaften von
einem Storage
ihr habt eine Cloud VM und ihr braucht Storage
da drauf
das Speed ist mir zu ungenau
Lese Schreibgeschwindigkeit ist
mir vielleicht auch fast
ein bisschen zu ungenau ja ok
sagen wir das ist ok
ja ok
Integrity wäre das 4te
also
ja es ist ok es wurde mehr oder weniger
alles schon genannt deswegen kriegt jetzt keiner
explizit einen Sub
aber
ihr seid nicht schnell also
Haltbarkeit juckt mich im Cloud Umfeld nicht
Lese Schreibgeschwindigkeit
ist das erste
das ist tatsächlich wichtig
sagen wir mal das bezieht sich hauptsächlich auf
sequentielles Schreiben oder sequentielles
Lesen
am Stück du hast irgendwas
2 Terabyte
großes willst das draufschreiben
zack bumm soll einfach
flutschen 600 700
MB die Sekunde
Gigabyte pro Sekunde
das ist das erste
das nächste ist ja gut
Größe ist auch nicht unwichtig
RAM ist eigentlich wurscht
Ausfallsicherheit tatsächlich da hab ich gar nicht dran gedacht
Integrität ja ist aber im Cloud Umfeld meistens
kein Problem also dass da irgendwelche
Bits auf einmal nicht richtig sind das kommt
selten vor IOPS und
Latency das sind also für mich
auch die 3 Sachen also einmal das hier
IOPS und Latency
und das
Problem ist was sehr viele
Cloud Anbieter haben und mit sehr
viele ist eigentlich wurscht es hat definitiv
Azure das Problem und definitiv Google das
Problem wenn ihr bei Google
ich nenne es Google weil damit hab ich
mich die letzten Wochen hauptsächlich beschäftigt
wenn ihr bei Google hingeht und denkt
das nur weil ihr
Moment
so wenn ihr jetzt bei Google
hingeht und denkt ich kauf
mir
ja da gibt es hier ich also
Balance Persistent Discs sind glaube ich Festplatten
so Oldschool Dinger also ihr denkt
ihr seid schon mal richtig nice
und ihr kauft euch
SSD bei Google
dann legt ihr ne VM an und sagt ich brauche
15 Terabyte
SSD das geht glaube ich bis 65 Terabyte
hoch ja hier steht es ja auch also ihr sagt
Google ich brauche
64 Terabyte
SSD und dann taucht bei euch
auf eurer VM auf eurem Server
taucht dann irgendwo
Dev SDA oder
sowas auf oder STB STC wie auch immer
ein ganz normales Block Device
das Problem ist aber das täuscht
das sieht zwar aus wie ein Block Device
auf eurer Kiste was ihr da von Google
bekommt es ist aber kein Block
Device im na doch es ist ein Block Device
es ist aber kein lokal
angeschlossener
Storage das geht immer übers Netzwerk
also sprich wenn ihr euch sowas kauft hier bei
Google dann ist es unter der Haube
ich meine hey ich war noch nicht bei Google
im Rechenzentrum und weiß wie die es wirklich
aufgebaut haben dann ist das irgendwie
ein bisschen was in Richtung sowas
irgendwas in der
Richtung ich glaube nicht dass es
ISCSD ist oder
iSCSI wie es manche Leute aussprechen
aber sowas in der Richtung ist das
sprich das ist Block
Storage
über Netzwerk
und Google selbst sagt
dass
das ganz toll ist aber
ja aber sie sagen
auch guck mal hier
Performance SSD und das täuscht
ist teuer wenn ihr euch da 13TB
kauft könnt ihr über 1000€ im Monat für ausgeben
das ist ordentlich teuer also jede
jede kauft euch lieber
SSDs im Saturn anstatt in der Cloud
so so so Geschichten dafür hat es
ein paar Vorteile du kannst es automatisch replizieren
lassen zwischen verschiedenen
Adsets kopieren zwischen verschiedenen Projekten kopieren
und sowas
so das ist kein einzelnes
Drive das ist doch das Ding das ist
kein einzelnes Drive das ist aus irgendeinem Drive
Pool wo du das bekommst also von
irgendeinem ja von irgendeinem
SAN kriegst du da was zoniert
und das geht halt
über das Netzwerk
so und jetzt und jetzt kommt halt
das Ding Google sagt hier auch
das ist ganz toll für IOPS
und auch ganz toll für Übertragungs
Geschwindigkeit und es ist auch
ganz toll für
Latency aber ganz im Ernst
guck mal hier
Single Digit Millisecond
Latency
und ich zeig es euch nochmal was ich für eine Latenz
bei mir lokal auf meiner NVMe SSD
hab und übrigens das ist noch VM
auf Windows ist es nochmal die Hälfte
so hoch
ihr erkennt vielleicht den Unterschied
bei Google ist es ungefähr
so ja
4-5 Millisekunden also ich hab es getestet
ohne Cache direkt aufs Device
auch so 6-7 Millisekunden
und das ist halt
wenn ihr das mal vergleicht
langsam
im Vergleich zu wirklich
richtig lokal angeschlossenem
Storage von der Latenz her
also mit Latenz ist gemeint wenn du
eine nicht gecachete
IO Operation
machst
wie lange halt
der Zugriff im Endeffekt
Zugriff ist das falsche Wort
das Gesamtausführen
der Operation im Prinzip von
mach jetzt was
Storage zu hier hast du was
also die
nicht sequenziell sondern die Latenz
das dauert darauf zuzugreifen
so
ja kommen wir gleich zu Madminister
so und wenn ihr Anwendungen habt
die sehr Latenz
sensibel sind
dann taugt das nichts
dann taugt
das einfach nichts
und der Chat hat es ja auch
schon geschrieben
also im Millisekunden Bereich
9 Millisekunden 7-8 Millisekunden
das ist richtig langsam
das ist nicht so schlimm
aber mal als Beispiel
stellt euch mal vor ihr habt
und das ist jetzt wirklich ein praktisches Beispiel
von meinem alten Arbeitgeber
stellt euch vor ihr habt ein Storage
mit ganz vielen
kleinen Dateien drinnen
zum Beispiel ihr habt einen E-Mail Server
ihr habt einen Mail Server
mit 20 Terabyte E-Mails
ich weiß nicht wie viel es bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
gewesen ist aber das waren
E-Mail Bestände von mehreren Jahren
20 Terabyte E-Mails
ich glaube es waren sogar noch mehr
und E-Mails haben halt das Ding
das ist Text und oftmals relativ wenig
du hast Milliarden
kleine Furzdateien
ja
und das Ganze
wollt ihr
auf verschiedenen
Servern zur Verfügung stellen
zum Beispiel
also machen wir es mal konkret
ihr habt einen Storage wo die ganzen
E-Mail Sachen drauf liegen und ihr habt
3 Server die das E-Mail Handling
machen für die Customer die da drauf zugreifen
und ihr
mountet euch das zum Beispiel rein
über NFS
NFS ist auch so ein Ding das ist extrem
Latency abhängig weil das ja
für jeden Furz was es macht
übers Netzwerk gehen muss
ein Stat auf die Datei
und wieder zurück das ist
massiv langsam
wir haben es bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
ausprobiert NFS in Azure zu machen
es ist nicht benutzbar
du brauchst für die einfachsten
Sachen wir haben easy Sachen
ausprobiert so auflisten
von Dateianzahl im Verzeichnis
bei uns lokal auf dem
NFS keine Ahnung
eine halbe Sekunde
für paar Millionen Dateien
in der Cloud 53 Sekunden
das ist teilweise echt
für Datenbanken gerade wenn du
irgendwelche Datenbank
Replizierungsgeschichten machst und sowas
das ist der Killer
das kannst du nicht benutzen das funktioniert
nicht und die ganzen Cloud Anbieter
haben ähnliche Probleme verständlicher
Weise weil die den meisten
Storage über Netzwerk anbieten
kommen wir jetzt mal wieder zurück
ich sag gleich was zu Local SSD
kommen wir jetzt mal wieder zurück zu meiner Provider Auswahl
ja genau also
kommen wir mal wieder zurück zu meiner Provider Auswahl
ich hab mir gedacht ok
also ich hab es bei DigitalOcean
ausprobiert
aber Millisekunden ist halt wirklich krass
lokal angeschlossene NVMe
hat immer
ich mein
du musst dir allein schon mal die Länge der Kabel angucken
lokal bei dir auf dem Mainboard
versus über irgendein
Fiber Channel zu irgendeinem Storage oder sowas
aber das ist meist
da reden wir ja trotzdem nicht von 7-8 Millisekunden
genau
sondern von halt immer noch
im Rahmen
zumindest bin ich dann zu DigitalOcean gegangen
und hab mir das angeguckt
dacht ich mir so weißt du was komm easy
gehst mal bei DigitalOcean hin
guckst mal was die so haben
hab ich festgestellt ok guck mal
die haben Block Storage
und da kannst du dir
mal hier
Pricing DigitalOcean
da kannst du dir 15TB Storage holen
ist überhaupt kein Problem
guck hier Storage
kannst du dir holen
das geht noch weiter
da kannst du dir 15TB eingeben
also wunderbar
hab ich gemacht hab ich dran gehängt
7-8 Millisekunden Latency
das heißt
die machen genau den gleichen Kram
und dann bin ich auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen
Max weißt du was
scheiß drauf
hol dir einfach
irgendwo einen Server
hol dir irgendwo eine Dedicated Server Kiste
da kannst du dir einfach
die Kiste
Sieht wie echt aus, Leute. Wie echt. Es sieht so aus, als könnte das so aussehen in echt, ja?
Nein, gibt es nicht. Wundert mich. Es wundert mich extrem, dass es das nicht gibt.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass kein C-Compiler für diese Garmin-Sachen gibt.
Wundert mich aber echt, dass noch keiner gebaut hat.
Übrigens, die Anzeige hier unten ist halt komplett sinnlos, dass sie da angezeigt wird.
Ihr seht hier übrigens auch den eigentlichen Grund, warum ich sowas gebaut habe.
Seht ihr? Bei Garmin selbst kannst du plus zwei Felder hier unter der Map anzeigen lassen.
Und mit meinem Datafield kannst du drei Felder anzeigen lassen.
Und noch viel besser, ihr seht, alle drei Sekunden wechselt das.
Seht ihr? Hier zeigt der Watt an, hier zeigt der... Moment, warum zeigt der überhaupt...
So, besser. Guck mal. Also es funktioniert schon relativ gut.
Der zeigt euch die Pulsfrequenz an, der zeigt die Watt, die man tritt an, wie schnell man fährt.
Und hier wechselt er zwischen... Also man kann die Felder auswählen und sie wechseln alle drei Sekunden, wenn man mehr als eine Sache...
Okay, Chat. Ich muss... Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, es haben genug Leute subscribed heute, dass das eindeutig ist, warum das so ist.
Weil das hier ein Bild ist, wo eine Wattanzeige drauf ist.
Okay, ich brauche ein anderes Bild, das verwirrt die Leute. Alles klar.
Ich brauche ein anderes Bild, wo keine Wattanzeige drauf ist.
Ja. Top.
Ey Leute, wir machen das anders. Passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
Achso, du meinst, warum die Wattanzeige hier unten doppelt ist? Einfach zu Testzwecken.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass die Wattanzeige doppelt ist.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Jaja, da hast du schon recht. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Passt mal auf. Paint. Zack.
Wir schneiden das jetzt aus. Okay, so.
Ohne die Anzeige hier unten dran.
Und jetzt... Oh, wie paste ich das jetzt unter Linux?
Ähm... Moment.
XClip. Paste image. Wie geht das?
How to copy image to clipboard to... How to copy an image?
Äh... Linux. Save clipboard image.
Wie funzt denn das?
Copy image from clipboard to file. Okay, was?
XClip. Und was? XClip?
Jetzt wird es aber super advanced.
Selection. Clipboard.
Minus T. Targets. Minus O.
Ach, als was ich das speichern kann. Okay, und jetzt?
XClip. Selection. Clipboard.
Minus T. Image.
PNG.
Minus O. Nach blub.png.
Und das hat jetzt funktioniert?
Da habe ich meine Zweifel. Guck mal mal.
Image can't blub. Es hat funktioniert.
Es ist einfach da.
Image aus dem Clipboard gesaved mit Command Line.
Richtig, richtig advanceder Kram hier. So.
Und jetzt? Und jetzt kopieren wir das hier rüber.
Machen das so hin. Ah.
Top. Jetzt verwirrt es hoffentlich keinen mehr.
Excellent, oder? Excellent.
Äh, schon mit GT-Dings.
Ist das das, wo du ein GTA V fahren kannst?
Mit deinem Heimtrainer? Smarttrainer? Ne, ne.
Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Servus, will Pi-Hall plus Home Assistant plus InfluxDB betreiben.
Warum eigentlich InfluxDB?
Lieber Pi 4B 8GB SSD oder jetzt lieber ein Pi 5?
Ich denke mal, dass die sich verbrauchstechnisch
beide nicht sonderlich viel nehmen werden.
Unter den Voraussetzungen, dass du die zum größten Teil
eh nicht Volllast hast.
Oder die vor sich hin rum eideln.
Also der Raspberry Pi mit der SSD ist eine ganz gute Basis
für Home Assistant. Pi-Hall kannst du da auch drauf hauen
und sonst was. Die Sache ist halt die,
wenn du Home Assistant laufen lassen willst auf dem Raspberry Pi,
dann musst du das direkt auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen lassen.
Und dann bist du halt ein bisschen drauf angewiesen,
was es dort schon für Addons gibt.
Ne, brauchst du nicht.
Home Assistant speichert jetzt standardmäßig eine SQLite-Datenbank auf der SSD.
Das ist voll und ganz ausreichend. Brauchst kein InfluxDB.
Kann ich den Home Assistant auf einem 1€ Ionos VPS?
Das kannst du theoretisch machen.
Ich glaube, dass die 1€ Kiste ein bisschen wenig RAM hat.
Ich glaube, die hat bloß 256MB RAM.
Ich glaube, das reicht nicht. Kannst du machen?
Das ist halt die Frage, was es dir bringt.
Du kommst ja von dort nirgendwo dran bei dir daheim.
Ja, aber ob Pi 4 oder 5?
Ich würde sagen, für den Anwendungszweck wird es nicht allzu viel Unterschied machen.
Vielleicht wartest du, bis der Pi 5 raus ist, um dir dann Pi 4 zu kaufen.
Dann ist er ein bisschen billiger.
Aber wohlgemerkt, je nachdem, was du mit der Kiste alles machen möchtest später,
ist ein Raspberry Pi eventuell auch gar nicht was Gutes.
Also möchtest du das irgendwann mal als Netzwerkspeicher verwenden,
dann kannst du es vergessen mit dem Raspberry Pi 4.
Mit einem 5er vielleicht schon ein bisschen eher,
aber Raspberry Pi sind allgemein keine guten Netzwerkstorages.
Echt? Ja, dann kannst du da drauf...
Ja, aber mit einem Gigabyte wird es auch knapp.
Aber ansonsten wird sich das nicht viel nehmen.
Stimmt, sind die eigentlich lieferbar?
Was sagst du bloß zu Unraid? Ich habe einen Unraid daheim.
Richtig glücklich bin ich damit nicht,
aber im Vergleich zu den anderen Sachen taugt es noch ganz gut.
Also für den Heimbereich ist Unraid schon in Ordnung.
Es läuft auch schön aus dem RAM von einem USB-Stick gebootet.
Also richtig glücklich bin ich damit nicht,
aber es ist das Beste, was ich bisher gefunden habe.
Was sagt eigentlich Barry Bass zum Raspberry Pi 5?
Die Dinger sind echt teuer.
Kann man hier nicht auswählen,
dass man einen Raspberry Pi 5 haben will?
Ja, 5.
Not available.
Alter.
Da könnte man fast denken, ich rauche, Mann.
Ich rauche aber nicht.
Voll verschluckt an mir selbst.
Ja, der Raspberry Pi 4 braucht schon...
Die sagen, du sollst das offizielle 5,1 Volt 3 Ampere Netzteil benutzen.
Es geht aber auch mit vielen anderen Sachen.
Und beim Raspberry Pi 5 wird es ähnlich sein.
Wobei der dann tatsächlich echt wohl Probleme bekommt.
Aber Raspberry Pis kacken ja in der Regel nicht ab,
sondern tacken sich dann runter.
Das geht schon.
Ach ja.
Zum Thema Raspberry Pi 5.
Zum Thema Husten.
Ich habe euch doch letztens erzählt,
mein Vater war im Krankenhaus.
Der hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Sein zweiter schon.
Da war ich letztens bei ihm.
Ich habe ihm seinen Drucker angeschlossen.
Ratet mal, was das Erste war,
was ich gesehen habe, was er gemacht hat.
Zigarette, korrekt.
Der hat eine Zigarette im Mund gesteckt und hat geraucht.
Da habe ich auch gesagt,
meinst du nicht,
nach einem Herzinfarkt wäre es vielleicht gut,
nicht zu rauchen.
Daraufhin hat er gesagt,
ist doch auch egal.
Sogar der Arzt hat gesagt,
das macht jetzt auch keinen Unterschied mehr.
Im Leben hat der Arzt das nicht gesagt.
Im Leben nichts.
Ihr seid im Krankenhaus.
Die haben euch gerade behandelt.
Herzinfarkt und alles.
Der Arzt fragt euch dann,
rauchen sie?
Du sagst, klar, ich rauche jetzt auch weiter.
Dann sagt der Arzt,
kein Problem, macht eh nichts.
Machen sie ruhig weiter.
Ganz bestimmt.
Laut seiner Aussage bringt das nichts.
Er kann ruhig weiter rauchen.
Ich habe auch gedacht,
ein bisschen selber dran schultern.
Es wird noch besser.
Ich habe euch ja schon mal
die Pains Champ-Storys erzählt.
Mein Vater ist jetzt, glaube ich, 75.
Vielleicht erinnert sich noch der eine oder andere.
Ich habe euch das ja schon mal erzählt.
Aber er hat mir letztens erzählt,
er hat jetzt wieder eine Freundin.
Und zwar in der Karibik.
Chetke, ratet mal,
wie alt seine Freundin in der Karibik ist.
Freundin in Anführungszeichen.
Ich gehe davon aus,
das ist so eine typische Geschichte.
Wir machen Rentnern schöne Augen,
damit wir ein bisschen Geld abgreifen können.
Aber ich denke,
solange sich beide Seiten der Sache bewusst sind,
dann soll es halt so sein.
26.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass der wirklich denkt,
dass die was von ihm will,
weil sie ihn so toll findet.
Er macht so viele Probleme die ganze Zeit mit irgendwas.
Und sich selbst vor allem.
Kann er nicht irgendwas Normales machen für sein Alter?
Modelleisenbahnen bauen?
Oder am Fenster stehen
und irgendwelche Leute anscheißen,
die schräg parken oder sowas.
Was Opas halt so machen normalerweise.
Aber nee, geht nicht.
Der muss so Zeug machen.
Und sie haben ihn ja auch schon beschissen.
Er war ja dort im Urlaub.
Ich will nicht wissen, was sie da getrieben haben.
Er war ja da wohl irgendwie auch im Urlaub.
Und als er vom Urlaub wiederkam,
gab es zufälligerweise,
ganz zufälligerweise,
Abbuchungen von seinem Konto.
Unberechtigte Abbuchungen von seinem Konto.
Wo die wohl herkommen können?
Es kann nicht sein,
dass ihn da jemand beschissen hat oder so.
Nein.
Da geht doch dein komplettes Erbe drauf.
Also wenn ich von einem nix erbe,
dann ist es mein Vater.
Der Kerl hat so viele Probleme.
Ich bin mit dem ja nicht so dicke.
Ich hatte mit meinem Vater jahrzehntelang nichts zu tun.
Und eigentlich habe ich mit meinem Vater jetzt auch nichts zu tun.
Außer, dass er mich ab und zu anpumpt,
was Geld angeht.
Und mich fragt,
wenn bei ihm die Technik nicht geht.
Ich versuche so weit wie möglich zu ignorieren.
Ich hatte über 20 Jahre mit dem nix zu tun.
Ich hatte länger,
locker 25 Jahre mit dem nix zu tun.
Nicht geredet,
nichts gemacht und so.
Ich habe da keine großartige Beziehung zu dem.
Zumindest erben werde ich von dem garantiert nix.
Dann brauche ich nichts erben.
Dann gibt es nix.
Aber jetzt kommt der neue Hammer.
26 jährige Freundin in der Karibik.
Eines der Dinge,
die mich immer extrem aufregt,
ist, dass er sich permanent
irgendeinen Blödsinn an den Haaren herbeizieht,
ausdenkt,
sich zusammenschwindelt,
um einen dazu zu bringen, Sachen zu machen,
die man will.
Die haben ihm das Konto gesperrt,
weil es unberechtigte Abbuchungen gegeben hat.
Daraufhin hat er Probleme.
Er hat jegliches Bargeld ausgegeben.
Daraufhin hat er übelst Panik bei mir geschoben.
Wie kannst du deinen Vater verhungern lassen?
Er ruft mich an, erzählt mir so Zeug.
Ich hatte mit dir 25 Jahre nichts zu tun.
Als ich ihm gesagt habe,
wir hatten nie großartig was miteinander zu tun.
Das Einzige, was ich höre,
ist, wenn du Kohle brauchst,
ich will nicht, dass du verhungerst.
Ich bringe dir mal 50 Euro vorbei.
Bin ich da über eine Stunde hingefahren,
dann haben wir 55 Euro vorbeigebracht.
Dann habe ich gesagt,
du wirst schon nicht verhungern.
Jetzt habe ich vergessen,
worauf ich eigentlich drauf hinaus wollte.
Jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Ich habe ihm erst gesagt,
wir hatten 25 Jahre nichts zu tun.
Ich habe ihm gesagt,
du wirst schon nicht verhungern.
Dann habe ich gesagt,
Jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Ich habe ihm erst gesagt,
wir hatten 25 Jahre nichts zu tun.
Eigentlich will ich auch nicht großartig.
Ich wollte nur meine Ruhe.
Er hat gemerkt,
dass er bei mir nicht weiterkommt.
Ich habe ihm 50 Euro gebracht.
Dann hat er auf einmal erzählt,
seine Freundin in der Karibik wäre schwanger.
Oder war schwanger.
Wenn er denen kein Geld schickt,
dann verhungert das Kind.
Das ist kein Witz.
Das hat er mir sinngemäß erzählt.
Er hat sich random Geschichten ausgedacht,
dass ich mich so unter Druck gesetzt fühle,
dass ich ihm Geld überweise.
Hand aufs Herz.
Ihr hattet bessere Beziehungen zu eurem Vater.
Ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen.
Wie das ist.
Aber er ist ein sehr weird Champ.
Das ist sehr weird Champ.
Ein Scammer ist mein Vater wirklich.
Gar nicht in Bezug auf diese Sache.
Mit den 50 Euro.
Der war ja fast im Knast.
Wegen Betrug.
Er hat wirklich Leute gescampt.
Er war nicht im Knast,
aber fast im Knast gelandet.
Wegen Betrug damals.
Der hatte vor Internet,
lange vor Internet,
das war dann wahrscheinlich 1990,
hatte der eine Partnervermittlung in Hessen.
Der hat die Leute übelst gescampt dort.
Ich erzähle euch mal,
wie er die Leute gescampt hat.
Was übrigens,
wo er freigesprochen wurde,
das war kein Betrug,
die Klientinnen,
die sich dort angemeldet haben,
bei der Partnervermittlung,
die muss ordentlich Mitgliederbeitrag bezahlen.
Dementsprechend haben die erwartet,
dass nette Herren vermittelt werden.
Was hat er gemacht?
Mein Vater hatte einen Pool aus 5, 6,
sehr optisch ansprechende,
sehr optisch ansprechende Herren am Start.
Wahrscheinlich eine ganze Ecke jünger,
als die Omas, die sich da angemeldet haben.
Er hat dann aus diesem Pool von den 5 Leuten
allen Omas die heimgeschickt,
als wir jemanden für sie gefunden haben.
Die sind dann heimgefahren zu den Omas,
haben denen schöne Augen gemacht,
und haben ihnen erzählt, wie toll sie sind.
Die Omas waren alle total verzückt,
und haben richtig krass Mitgliedsbeitrag reingebuttert.
In diese Partnervermittlung.
Und zumindest, die wollten ihn ja verklagen,
dann am Ende, als das alles rausgekommen ist.
Aber der wurde freigesprochen,
weil der Vertrag, da stand das drin.
Also in dem Vertrag,
was die Leute unterschrieben haben,
stand das mehr oder weniger sinngemäß drin.
Dass hier nichts vermittelt wird,
und keine Garantie auf irgendwas besteht.
Es muss wohl so gewesen sein,
dass sogar der Richter während der Verhandlung,
ich sag mal Frau Müller,
der Richter muss sogar die Frau Müller
während der Verhandlung gefragt haben,
wie kann man sowas unterschreiben.
Er hat wirklich viel gescammt in seinem Leben.
Aber er wurde freigesprochen am Ende.
Das ist der Rentnertrick,
bevor es den Rentnertrick gab.
Ganz im Ernst, der hat wirklich viele Leute gescammt.
Zumindest bisher.
Also Verwandtschaft hat er eigentlich nie gescammt.
Das war kein Scam, korrekt.
Du hast das richtig erkannt.
Ja, korrekt.
So sieht es aus.
Man kann sicherlich sagen,
dass das aus moralischer Sicht durchaus gescammt war.
Aber aus rechtlicher Sicht nicht.
Ja, korrekt.
Und ganz im Ernst,
wenn du dir heute den ganzen Scheiß anguckst,
wie heute die Leute verarscht werden,
wie vielleicht nicht nur die Omas veräppelt werden.
Michael, 50 Milliarden, danke für den Sub.
Lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Das ist heute alles der gleiche Scheiß.
Ein bisschen angepasst an die jeweilige Zeit.
Heute, ohne Scheiß.
Wisst ihr, was mein Vater heute machen würde?
Wenn er heute in dem Alter wäre,
der würde heute 100% Comedygruppe-Scam machen.
Das würde einfach so gut passen zu ihm.
Der wäre einer der Ersten gewesen,
der Comedygruppe machen würde.
Jetzt nicht mehr, jetzt ist es ja ausgelutscht.
Aber wenn er heute 35, 40 wäre,
wenn er in meinem Alter wäre,
und das mitgekriegt hätte,
der hätte einen Comedygruppe-Scam,
das wäre der Erste gewesen.
Der hat natürlich auch alles wieder ausgegeben.
Mein Vater hat damals massig Kohle bekommen,
aber halt alles ausgegeben.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die nehme ich ihm heute noch übel.
Weil, wie gesagt, während dieser Zeit
war der wirklich super im Business drin.
Super im Business drin.
Das waren noch keine Euro, das war noch Mark.
Der hat so viel im Monat verdient,
dass der 10.000 Euro im Monat
einfach für Random-Zeug ausgeben konnte.
Äh, nicht Euro, Mark.
10.000 Mark im Monat konnte der einfach mal
random für Just for Fun ausgeben.
Also der hat damals wirklich richtig Asche gemacht.
So, und jetzt kommt es.
Ich war damals noch nicht alt, keine Ahnung.
5, 6 oder so.
Meine Mutter, alleinerziehend mit mir,
hat damals gearbeitet in der Arztpraxis,
hat kaum was verdient.
Und der hat keinen Unterhalt bezahlt.
Und meine Mutter hat dann zu ihm irgendwann mal gesagt,
jetzt hier, wie sieht es aus, bezahl halt mal Unterhalt.
Und daraufhin muss er wohl geantwortet haben,
ich kann keinen Unterhalt bezahlen, weil,
wenn ich nicht mindestens 10.000 Mark im Monat für mich habe,
dann kann ich nicht leben oder so.
War die Aussage von ihm damals.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen, Alter.
Es ist obviously, es ist nicht möglich.
Also, Leute, ihr kennt das Problem vielleicht auch,
unter 10.000 Euro im Monat
kommt man nicht aus.
Oder? Es geht einfach nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht überhaupt,
unter 10.000 Euro im Monat.
Geht einfach nichts. Das geht nicht.
Das ist nicht möglich, unter 10.000 Euro im Monat.
Und dann bist du obdachlos in Frankfurt.
Der hat das richtige Crying-Z Mindset gehabt.
Das wäre heute so ein richtiger Lifestyle
und komm in die Gruppe, Coach.
Das kann ich mir richtig gut vorstellen bei ihm.
Richtig gering verdient.
Der hat es aber damals auch echt zelebriert.
Mit 3 BMWs und allem möglichen Zeug.
Der hat schon geklotzt und nicht gekleckert damals,
was Geld ausgeben angeht.
Deswegen hat er heute auch keins mehr.
Weil er alles zum Fenster rausgeschmissen hat.
Naja, also, ich sage euch.
Zumindest, um das jetzt mal abzukürzen.
Da wollte er, wie gesagt,
er wollte mir das Geld aus den Rippen leiern.
Da hat er sich immer neue Sachen ausgedacht.
Bis arme Kinder verhungern müssen,
wenn ich ihm kein Geld überweise.
Richtig krasses Zeug.
Das regt mich am meisten drauf,
dass er sich immer so random Zeug ausdenkt,
um einen dazu zu bringen, das zu machen, was man will.
Natürlich stehen die auf ihm, weil er da Geld hinüberweist.
Aber jetzt sitze ich vorm PC
und labere mit random Leuten online.
So sieht es aus.
Aber es ist für mich das Beste, was ich machen könnte.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich würde offline mit euch reden.
Das wäre ja noch schlimmer.
Also für euch und für mich.
Aber das eigentliche, worauf ich rauswollte jetzt.
Also um diese ganze Story drumherum.
Das Erste war, dass ich ihn nach dem Herzinfarkt
mit der Kippe im Mund in der Wohnung sitzen habe sehen.
Und das Nächste, was er zu mir gesagt hat,
eine typische Antwort von meinem Vater,
wo es darum ging, wie er versorgt wird.
Da hat er gemeint,
es kommt jetzt regelmäßig eine Pflegerin von der Krankenkasse.
Sie zieht ihn um und kümmert sich darum.
Eigentlich müsste der in irgendein Wohnheim.
Aber den schmeißt sie da raus.
Naja.
Zumindest das Nächste, was er dann gesagt hat.
Aber das ist alles nicht so schlimm.
Und ich kann das jetzt nicht auf Twitch sagen,
was er genau gesagt hat.
Weil das ist extrem monkatos.
Deswegen werde ich das jetzt etwas verpacken
in kompatiblere Twitch-Sprache.
Dann hat er gesagt zu mir,
es ist nicht illegal, was er gesagt hat,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall Twitch-Toss.
Ja, aber ich kenne da 2 Spanierinnen.
Die bestelle ich mir jetzt.
Die kümmern sich dann um mich.
Fuck, Alter.
Das Erste, was dir einfällt,
wenn du aus dem Krankenhaus kommst mit dem Herzinfarkt,
sind deine Krankenpflegerinnen.
Weiß ich nicht, welche Leute das sind.
Oh, meine Güte, Alter.
Und da habe ich ihn auch gefragt,
meinst du nicht, die bescheißen dich?
Die kommen doch nicht aus reiner Nächstenliebe zu dir.
Außerdem, du hast eine Mini-Wohnung.
Wie soll das hier mit 3 Leuten funktionieren?
Und dann habe ich gesagt,
du kannst machen, was du willst.
Und ich haue jetzt einfach wieder ab.
Und dann hat er noch gemeint,
und jetzt wird es richtig cringe,
hat er noch gemeint,
die Spanierinnen holt er sich ja nicht zum Pflegen.
Die dürfen ihn dann nachts massieren.
Ich will es nicht wissen, ich muss unbedingt weg.
Ich muss ganz schnell weg, Alter.
Naja, zumindest ein paar Tage später,
ein paar Tage später,
hat er mir eine E-Mail geschrieben.
Es kommen jetzt doch keine Spanierinnen,
sondern das macht er doch nicht,
weil dann wird er nicht gesund.
Und wisst ihr, warum?
Ich bin gerade über das Kabel gerollt.
Ich hoffe, das tut jetzt wieder.
Geht das jetzt?
Test, Test, Blub, Blub, Blub.
Ja, geht.
Und wisst ihr, warum ich denke,
dass sie nicht gekommen sind?
Er hat mir geschrieben, er hat die wieder abbestellt.
Aber ich persönlich glaube,
die sind einfach nicht aufgetaucht.
Weil denen auch gedämmert ist,
oder es gibt gar keine Spanierinnen.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Aber das ist so peinlich alles.
Welcher Rentner mit 75 kommt auf so Ideen?
Kann er nicht irgendwas ein bisschen weniger
stressiges machen?
Was machen Leute mit 75 normalerweise?
Sich über Falschparker aus dem Fenster aufregen,
Fernsehen gucken,
den ganzen Tag beim Bäcker sitzen
und nur einen Kaffee trinken.
Irgendwie Rasen mähen.
Keine Ahnung.
Der macht die ganze Zeit
irgendeinen Scheiß, Mann.
Der in die Hose geht.
Der hat eine Privatinsolvenz gemacht vor ein paar Jahren
und jetzt schon wieder Schulden.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Aber wie kann man das auf die Reihe kriegen?
Leute, ich sag euch,
das ist echt nicht normal.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ja, er soll Puzzle spielen und Solitär spielen
oder irgendwelche Mobile-Pay-to-Win-Geschichten.
Letztens hat er mich wieder angerufen.
Er hat sich schon wieder von seinem Konto ausgesperrt.
Bei ihm weißt du nie, stimmt das, was er sagt?
Oder hat er es sich ausgedacht?
Ganz egal ist es mir trotzdem irgendwo nicht.
Es ist echt super anstrengend, Leute.
Mega anstrengend.
MonkaS.
Richtig MonkaS.
Mir wäre es auch lieber mit Solitär spielen.
Eigentlich wollte ich mich um meine Garmin-App kümmern.
Ich glaube, den Streamtitel haben wir heute genau 5 Minuten verfolgt.
Ich habe noch gar nicht getestet,
ob ich mit meinem Finger gescheit tippen kann.
Es gibt übrigens etwas Neues von der Versicherung.
Beziehungsweise von meinem Anwalt.
Der hat jetzt an die Versicherung geschrieben,
dass sie ungefähr 4.500 Euro kosten.
Wir hätten sie jetzt endlich mal überweisen sollen.
Also wenn ich Glück habe,
habe ich bald die Kohle.
Und ich kann jetzt mal langsam nach einem neuen Fahrrad gucken.
Ich kann mir das Fahrrad auch schon kaufen,
bevor ich das Geld habe.
Aber das ist das fürs Fahrrad.
Aber ich bin mir noch gar nicht so genau sicher,
was ich mir kaufen soll.
Entweder kaufe ich mir exakt das gleiche Fahrrad wieder.
Aber ich glaube nicht.
Was war mit dem Rad?
Ich wurde auf dem Fahrradweg von einem Auto umgefahren.
Und jetzt ist das Fahrrad kaputt.
Ist das alte Schrott oder lässt es sich fixen?
Ne, es lässt sich nicht fixen.
Mit dem Finger.
Ich habe mir den Finger geschnitten heute Morgen.
Ja, das wird auch mal Zeit.
Also, das alte Fahrrad hat laut dem Gutachter
noch einen Restwert von 60 Euro oder sowas.
Es hat 3500 Euro gekostet.
Und das zu reparieren,
ist teurer als Neues zu kaufen.
Eine ganze Ecke teurer.
Aber ist ja auch klar,
der Rahmen ist nicht ganz.
Das ist ein Carbon Rahmen,
der einiges abbekommen hat an Kratzern.
Zumindest was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist,
es ist so gut wie alles im Arsch.
Also Leute, die Schaltung ist verbogen.
Der Sattel ist zerkratzt.
Der Lenker ist zerkratzt.
Der Rahmen ist zerkratzt.
Die Pedale sind zerkratzt.
Was habe ich noch vergessen?
Die Kette geht noch.
Ähm, was ist?
Warte mal, ich drehe mich mal kurz um.
Okay, die Kette.
Ich glaube, die Kette ist das Einzige,
was man theoretisch noch verwenden könnte.
Das habe ich mir auch schon angeguckt.
Zumindest eine gute Sache hat es.
Ich habe mir so einen Heimtrainer gekauft.
Nö, mache ich nicht.
Ich habe das Ding auch aktuell auf dem Heimtrainer stehen.
Weil auf die Straße gehe ich damit nicht mehr.
Dann fällt mir das komplett noch auseinander.
Aber auf dem Heimtrainer, da ist es egal,
dass die Schaltung 3 Gänge überspringt beim Schalten.
Nein, einen Wahoo Kick Record.
So ein Ding, wo man das Hinterrad ausbaut
und direkt drauf macht.
Und deswegen, ich werde das Fahrrad einfach
damit fahren.
Da ist auch egal, wenn es auseinander fällt.
Und ob der Lenker verkratzt ist.
Dann kaufe ich mir jetzt ein neues.
Eigentlich wollte ich Broggers Stelz machen heute.
Seid ihr mir böse, wenn wir noch eine halbe Stunde
schwätzen und das nächste Mal Broggers Stelz machen?
Ich glaube, so viel können wir heute eh nicht mehr machen.
Ich sehe schon, Rage Mode activated.
5 Uhr, was?
Was ist um 5 Uhr?
Ach, er ist 5.
Ja, aber 18 Uhr wollte ich was essen.
Und ich bin schon 2 Stunden on.
Ich zeige euch zumindest mal, Leute.
Eins machen wir auf jeden Fall noch.
Ich zeige euch mal, was ich gebaut habe.
Weil das neue doch jetzt schon deutlich besser aussieht
als das alte, was ich gebaut habe.
Ich bin um das jetzt nochmal 2 Minuten,
um das abzuschließen.
Also entweder kaufe ich mir das gleiche Fahrrad nochmal.
Wobei ich persönlich eigentlich darauf schiele,
kein Shimano Di2 mehr zu kaufen.
Nicht, weil ich das schlecht gefunden hätte.
Ganz im Gegenteil.
Ich fand die elektronische Schaltung extremly Pog.
Das Dumme, was mir überhaupt nicht gefällt,
ist, dass das so ein komplett Closed System ist.
Du kannst beispielsweise,
also hier oben auf dem Lenker hast du Knöpfe.
Man sieht es nicht richtig,
aber hierneben sind Knöpfe.
Damit kann man, wenn man die mit seinem Fahrradcomputer gepaart hat,
beispielsweise beim Garmin die Seiten umschalten.
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Das ist cool.
Das funktioniert mit dem Garmin.
Aber nachdem Shimano der Meinung ist,
dass es ein komplett Closed Sourced Bluetooth Protokoll ist,
was nur auserwählte Hersteller benutzen dürfen,
ist natürlich Custom Integration extrem doof.
Ich könnte zum Beispiel aus so einem Garmin Plugin hier
gar nicht auf meine Schaltungssachen zugreifen.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
wie spricht man die Dinge eigentlich aus?
Sagen bei den Videos alle immer SRAM,
aber ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob man die nicht vielleicht sogar SRAM ausspricht.
Sagen alle immer SRAM.
SRAM ist Open, was den Funkstandard angeht.
Da kann man theoretisch sogar so abgedrehtes Zeug machen,
wie die Buttons
von der SRAM-Schaltung
mit einem Plugin abgreifen
und damit sein Hoftor aufmachen,
wenn man das integriert bekommt über sein Smart Home.
Prinzipiell ist es scheißegal zum Fahrradfahren.
Es macht keinen Unterschied,
ob es so eine Schaltung ist oder so eine Schaltung.
Klar kannst du sicherlich sagen,
vielleicht in ganzen Nuancen das eine oder das andere,
aber eigentlich macht es keinen Unterschied.
Ich bin ein Fan von Basteln
und umso offener die Sachen sind,
die Funkprotokolle und Sachen, die man damit machen kann,
umso lieber ist es mir.
D.h. ich bin aktuell tatsächlich am Überlegen,
ob ich mir das neue Fahrrad kaufe
mit SRAM elektronischer Schaltung.
Eventuell, und das ist auch das Gute bei SRAM,
du kannst deutlich mehr Komponenten miteinander verbinden
und das funktioniert auch mit SHIMANO.
SHIMANO hat da so, du musst das mit dem und dem verwenden
und das funktioniert nur das zusammen.
Bei SRAM kannst du viel mehr Komponenten miteinander mischen.
Du kannst z.B. die Schalthebel nehmen
von dem Straßenset
und eine Mountainbike-Schaltung dran machen.
Das geht bei SHIMANO nicht gescheit,
das geht bei SRAM easy,
also aus den Gesichtspunkten tendiere ich aktuell
zu irgendeiner SRAM elektronischen Schaltung,
die vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Übersetzung noch hat,
weil die vom aktuellen Rad hat 40 Zähne vorne,
42 hinten,
damit kommt man gut überall hoch,
außer dort, wo ich letztens gefahren bin,
wo ich mit dem SRAM elektronisch gestartet bin.
Da kann ich nicht so viel machen,
aber dort, wo ich letztens gefahren bin,
16% hatte ich echt meine Probleme hochzukommen.
Also bei so richtig paar hundert Meter langen super steilen Dingern
würde ich mir vielleicht wünschen,
dass es hinten vielleicht ein 46er oder sogar ein 50er gibt.
Welchen FDP?
Das willst du nicht wissen,
mein FDP ist so dermaßen schlecht.
Ich habe ja auch erst angefangen zu fahren.
Ich müsste bei SWIFT mal den Test machen.
Ich kann dir aber sagen, was ich bei SWIFT fahre,
da fahre ich immer die 1,5 Watt pro Kilogramm Kategorien.
Das ist wirklich nicht gut.
Man sagt ja so,
1,1 bis 1,5 Watt pro Kilogramm
ist quasi Anfänger
und ab 2,5 Watt bist du dann fortgeschrittener
und darüber wird es dann richtig extrem.
Nur mal zum Vergleich,
dass ihr wisst, wie schlecht ich bin.
Bei der Tour de France fahren die Leute teilweise
den Berg mit 6,8 Watt das Kilogramm Körpergewicht hoch.
Aber gut, die wiegen auch nur die Hälfte von mir
und machen ihr ganzes Leben nichts anderes.
FDP ist die Wattanzahl,
die du treten kannst über 25 Minuten?
Eine Stunde?
Eine Stunde, genau.
Also die Leistung, die du bringen kannst über eine Stunde.
Ich weiß es nicht genau,
was ich habe,
aber meins ist schlecht.
Ich kann bei SWIFT dauerhaft
zu 130, 140 Watt fahren.
Alles mehr halte ich die Zeit nicht durch.
Aber es ist Übungszeit.
Nachdem ich noch nicht so lange Fahrrad fahre,
bin ich zuversichtlich, dass es besser wird.
Beim Rennen wurde es auch relativ schnell besser.
Nach 2 Monaten Rennen
bin ich von
über 8 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer
runter jetzt auf
ich glaube
5 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer.
Meine normale Strecke ist immer 6,2 Kilometer.
Ich denke,
dass es beim Fahrradfahren auch
schnell besser wird,
wenn ich es regelmäßig mache.
Deswegen ist es gut,
dass ich den Smart Trainer daheim habe.
Da kann ich jeden Tag
45 Minuten fahren.
Das bringt richtig was.
Gerade um die Beinmuskeln
daran zu gewöhnen.
Ich hätte selbst nicht gedacht,
dass mir das so viel Spaß macht.
Bevor ich um 18 Uhr essen gehe,
damit zumindest der Streamtitel
noch was mit der Realität zu tun hat.
Ich habe euch die App gezeigt,
es ist eigentlich ein Datafield.
Das was ihr hier unten seht,
ist das, was meine App macht.
Ich habe euch die alte App gezeigt,
ihr seht jetzt die neue.
Ihr werdet vielleicht feststellen,
dass es alles schon etwas besser ist.
Erstens kannst du jetzt 3 Werte anzeigen,
die alle 3 Sekunden
mehrere Werte durchswitchen können.
Das muss man nicht machen,
aber es kann man machen.
Man kann z.B. sagen,
ich möchte im ersten Datafeld
Watt, die man dritt anzeigen
plus Herzfrequenz.
Was noch viel cooler ist,
die Anzeige hier zeigt dir an,
in welcher Zone du dich befindest
und in welcher Powerzone man sich befindet.
Die Farben ändern sich auch hier,
je nachdem in welcher Zone man ist.
Ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen.
Jetzt ist es blau, habt ihr es gesehen?
Du musst dir auf diesen Feldern
gar keine Puls und Power anzeigen lassen,
weil du siehst deine Powerzone
und deine Herzfrequenz anhand dieses Strichs.
Das ist eigentlich sehr nice.
Jetzt zeige ich euch mal,
wie ich das ganze gebaut habe.
Wer jetzt denkt,
dass das nur im Simulator funktioniert,
das funktioniert nicht nur im Simulator.
Ich habe das sideloaded auf meinen Garmin Edge
und es funktioniert auf dem Garmin genauso wie hier.
Ich habe die Treppe hoch und runter gesprintet,
um zu gucken, ob das mit der Herzfrequenz funktioniert.
Wobei mit der Herzfrequenz ist das Ganze
noch ein bisschen verbuggt mit der Zonenanzeige.
Ich zeige euch kurz, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Was ich heute machen wollte,
ist noch mehr Datenfelder bauen,
was er anzeigen kann.
Aktuell kann er Herzfrequenz,
aber das kann er nicht.
Das Gesamte besteht aus 233 Zeilen in der Datei.
Dann haben wir noch eine Helper-MC.
Die ist fürs Calculaten,
für das Powerzonen-zu-Farbe-Umwandeln
und Herzfrequenz-zu-Farbe-Umwandeln.
Aber so viel macht das nicht.
Ich zeige euch das gleich noch im Detail.
Das war es.
Das hier ist Default.
Wie das Ganze funktioniert, ist folgendes.
Danke für den Sub.
Übrigens, Creator-Dashboard.
Ich habe bestimmt wieder Leute vergessen.
Samuel, dich habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Danke für den Sub.
Falls du noch da bist.
Ich war ein bisschen spät dabei.
Jetzt zeige ich euch kurz,
wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Das hier ist die Programmiersprache Monkey-C.
Die sind der Meinung,
sie brauchen eine eigene Programmiersprache.
Das ist ein wilder Verschnitt aus Javascript,
Lua,
Ruby,
Java und ein bisschen C.
Ganz, ganz weird.
Garmin-Plugins funktionieren folgendermaßen.
Man muss eine Klasse erstellen,
einen View erstellen.
Du musst eine Main-Klasse erstellen,
die von Datafield erbt.
Das reicht.
Darin musst du zwei Methoden überschreiben,
damit das Ganze funktioniert.
Das wird immer aufgerufen,
falls jemand Seiten wechselt auf dem Garmin
oder die Größe der Felder ändert.
Das ist wichtig, damit man weiß,
wie groß das Datenfeld überhaupt ist.
Die Größe des Datenfelds braucht man,
um die Position für den Inhalt berechnen zu können.
Dann muss man Initialize überschreiben.
Das ist ein Konstruktor.
Du musst OnUpdate überschreiben.
OnUpdate und OnCompute
wird vom Garmin-Betriebssystem aufgerufen,
wenn es denkt, dass man würdig ist,
CPU-Zeit zu bekommen.
Allerdings wird Compute und OnUpdate
unabhängig voneinander aufgerufen.
Es ist sinnvoll, dadurch,
dass man zweimal CPU-Zeit bekommt,
zum Rendern in OnUpdate
und zum Rendern in Compute,
die Werte, die man anzeigen möchte,
in Compute zu berechnen,
sich zwischen zu speichern
und in Update nur noch zu rendern.
Das ist das, was ich hier mache.
In Compute berechne ich,
was draufstehen soll
und gucke, ob es switchen soll
und speichere mir das.
Das können wir uns mal angucken.
Das ist das, was man machen muss,
damit die Garmin-Sachen was anzeigen.
Hat jemand von euch mal was gemacht
mit eigenen Windows-Forms-Controls?
Oder hat jemand mal ein Canvas benutzt
mit JavaScript von euch?
In irgendeiner Art und Weise
selbst mit irgendeinem UI-Framework
Sachen gemalt auf dem Bildschirm,
anstatt fertige Controls zu benutzen.
Falls ja, dann werdet ihr wahrscheinlich
Ähnlichkeiten erkennen.
Alle, die beispielsweise schon mal
Canvas benutzt haben, HTML-Canvas
und damit JavaScript reingemalt haben,
Du bekommst hier einen Device-Kontext.
Warum auch immer ist es DC genannt?
Ein Device-Kontext ist im Prinzip
eine Art Pointer zu deinem
Grafikspeicher.
Das stimmt nicht wirklich,
aber ich glaube, da kann man sich
das am besten darunter vorstellen.
Das ist ein Pointer zu deinem Grafikspeicher,
und das ist das,
was man mit dem Pointer machen kann.
Das heißt, man setzt hier
Vordergrundfarbe, Hintergrundfarbe,
dann macht man alles weg.
Was hier passiert ist,
er setzt Vordergrund und Hintergrund
auf Weiß, und ich male ein Rechteck
in Weiß über mein komplettes Feld,
und fängt an zu malen.
Interessant ist das hier,
das ist nämlich das, was den Text
und die Einheiten malt.
Das hier malt den Text,
und das ganze Zeug hier drum herum
ist nur dafür da zu berechnen,
wo der Text hin muss.
Ihr seht ja, das ist zentriert,
und es ist immer unten links.
So, dann gibt es was Neues,
das wusste ich letztes Mal noch nicht,
nämlich Icons malen.
Ihr seht, es gibt Icons,
es gibt ein Herz-Symbol und ein Power-Symbol.
Die liegen hier irgendwo rum
in dieser Resources Drawables XML.
Es gibt ein Herz-Icon und ein Bolt-Icon,
und die Icons sind dort
als 10x10 PNGs drin.
Das sind Tabler-Icons,
das sind nicht die Garmin-Icons.
Damit das Ganze ein bisschen besser
beherrschbar wird im Vergleich zu dem,
was ich das letzte Mal gebaut habe,
gibt es verschiedene Strukturen,
Klassen in dem Fall,
um die Daten zu speichern.
Es gibt Data-Field-Section,
das ist eins von diesen Kästchen hier,
und dann gibt es noch die Daten an sich,
die angezeigt werden,
und das kann man überschreiben
und einstellen, was er denn machen soll.
Das sieht so aus, das ist alles.
Es gibt eine Update-Methode,
an der Stelle guckt er einfach nach,
kann das Gerät die aktuelle Herzfrequenz auslesen?
Wenn ja, dann holen wir uns die aktuelle Herzfrequenz,
formatieren die als Zahl
und dann schreiben wir das in den Text rein
und beim nächsten Update wird es gerendert.
Fertig, so sieht das aus.
Ich glaube, Chetke,
versteht man ganz gut so einen einzelnen Abschnitt.
Ach ja, und der Trick,
dem können wahrscheinlich die meisten folgen,
der holt sich das Icon hier,
stellt Unit ein,
und hier unten liest er aus
und merkt sich den Text, was es sein muss.
Dementsprechend ist es auch relativ einfach,
das kann wechseln,
das wechselt aktuell alle 3 Sekunden
von Leistung auf Puls
und das funktioniert folgendermaßen,
es gibt hier ein
Array mit Sections
und da seht ihr schon,
in dem ersten Block
gibt es Heart Rate und Power Info,
im zweiten Block gibt es Temperatur und Speed Info
und im dritten gibt es nur Power Data Info.
Dementsprechend wechselt der dritte Block auch nicht,
aber die ersten 2 Blöcke wechseln zwischen
den verschiedenen Werten, die sie anzeigen sollen.
Man könnte da übrigens auch 3 reinschreiben,
aber dann wird es langsam ein bisschen unübersichtlich
und er wechselt alle 3 Sekunden das Feld.
Werden Emojis unterstützt? Nicht direkt.
Emojis kannst du nur als Bilder einbilden,
also die haben kein Imagefonds, der Emojis kann.
Das kannst du machen, ja das kannst du machen.
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür,
und zwar Data Info unterstützt folgende Sachen,
eine Unit,
eine Color, die ich noch nicht irgendwo verwende,
aber die könnte man verwenden,
ein Icon und einen Text.
200 und Unit W.
Heißt also, man könnte sagen,
wir können das mal machen exemplarisch,
dass ihr seht, oder hoffe ich zumindest,
dass das, wie ich das gebaut habe, eigentlich relativ simpel ist.
Gehen wir mal hier auf Speed Data Info.
Also was du jetzt machen könntest ist,
wann gibt es einen Dark Mode,
nachdem das Display draußen verwendet wird.
Aber ich glaube, niemand verwendet den.
Und aktuell rendert das ja auch
hartcoded auf schwarzem Vordergrund und weißem Hintergrund.
Also was du...
Alter, kann mal mein Bild bitte vorne bleiben,
sonst sieht das doch kacke aus.
Also was du jetzt natürlich machen könntest,
um unterschiedliche Farben anzuzeigen,
kannst du zum Beispiel hier die rausholen,
und dann kannst du so was machen wie,
sagen wir mal,
von der Idee her ist das eigentlich ganz einfach.
If Speed größer 20,
dann Color gleich
Graphics Red.
Color Red.
Und dann wird das rot.
Über 20 kmh.
So weit von der Idee her.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Rendern von der Farbe da schon eingebaut habe.
Also von der Idee her sollte das dann so funktionieren.
Guck mal, wie schnell das sein kann.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob ich das eingebaut habe,
dass er die Farbe rendert.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Wenn es nicht geht, können wir das mal schnell einbauen.
Das schaffen wir in 20 Minuten.
Ich muss nichts essen, aber ich habe Hunger.
Und Speed? Er zeigt das nicht an.
Aber er könnte es theoretisch anzeigen.
Dann gehen wir doch mal an die Stelle,
wo das Ganze gerendert wird.
Draw Data Field Sections.
Draw Text.
Im Prinzip easy.
Eigentlich müsste ich sagen,
Graphics Color ist
Data Color.
Ich habe es ja auch nicht gebildet.
Ich muss es ja einmal kompilieren.
Und dann sollte der Speed,
wenn er größer 5 ist,
eigentlich jetzt in Rot sein.
Schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Ich bin mir da noch etwas unschlüssig.
Und am Ende würde ich sagen,
stellen wir das nochmal.
Wir sollen das dann wieder zurückstellen.
Sollen wir die Einheiten mit Rot malen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Die Einheit sollte immer einheitlich
in Schwarz sein.
Machen wir es lieber so.
Bild.
Laden wir mal neu.
Ich habe bisher absichtlich keine Farben eingebaut.
Für die Zahlen.
Ich finde, es wird etwas unübersichtlich.
Das hat Farben, das hat Farben.
Da blickst du ja gar nicht mehr durch.
Die hier ändern sich ja auch.
Je nach Herzfrequenzregion und wie viel
Watt man gerade tritt.
Theoretisch könnte man sogar hingehen
und sagen, man macht 2 verschiedene Datafields.
Einmal Speed mit Color und einmal Speed ohne Color.
Oder irgendwie eine Option.
Am Anfang, ob man das haben möchte oder nicht.
Aber was ist denn ganz gut?
Speed, sagt mir mal ein paar sinnige Werte.
Wir reden hier nicht von Meilen pro Stunde,
weil wir sind nicht im Kona Land.
Sagt mir mal sinnvolle Werte.
Color zur Auswahl haben wir
Grau, Grün, Blau, Orange, Rot.
Ihr seid schon viel zu advanced.
Ich würde das theoretisch so handhaben,
wenn ich das jemals in den Garment Store pushen würde,
dann könnte ich das konfigurierbar machen über die App.
Nicht Durchschnitt, aktuelle Geschwindigkeit.
Wie sieht es aus, wenn die Sonne scheint?
Sieht man das Display gut?
Ja, das haben die gut gemacht.
Selbst wenn voll die Sonne drauf scheint, erkennt man es gut.
Man muss es auf jeden Fall konfigurierbar machen.
Wir können ja mal sagen,
der Default Speed ist
ganz klar
Graphics Black.
Wenn der Speed über 10 ist,
dann ist es relativ unsinnig,
etwas mit Farbe zu machen.
Man könnte höchstens sagen,
wenn der Speed über 25 ist,
dann machen wir Color Orange
und wenn der Speed über 10 ist,
dann machen wir Color Grün
und wenn der Speed über 30 ist,
dann sind wir schon super schnell,
wenn es Color Red ist.
Das könnte man auch machen.
Wenn du bergab fährst,
finde ich es eine gute Idee,
das könnte man als Warnung für bergrunter fahren.
Über 50, über 45,
über 45 ist Rot.
Übrigens, wir müssen das umdrehen,
sonst macht es komische Sachen.
Wenn der Speed über 40 ist,
ist es Orange,
wenn der Speed über 45 ist, ist es Rot.
Wenn ich das machen möchte,
dass das irgendjemand außer mir verwendet,
was ich eigentlich gar nicht vorhabe,
dann muss ich das über die Garmin App konfigurieren.
Da können die Leute selbst eintragen,
was sie eintragen wollen.
Dann müsste ich hier im Constructor laden.
Ich weiß noch nicht, wie das geht.
Da gibt es wahrscheinlich eine Konfig-Klasse,
wo man das rauslesen kann.
Aber Chat, es ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Am besten noch 30er-Zone.
Garmin SDK.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher,
das kann man nicht abfragen.
Apidox.
Du würdest bei Temperaturen was...
Sehr gute Idee.
Eiswarnung.
Da könnte man sogar
ein Schneeflocken-Symbol anzeigen lassen.
Das ist auch eine Sache,
was ich mir überlegt habe, was cool wäre.
Wenn man ein kombiniertes Batterie-Icon anzeigen lassen könnte.
Also ein Batterie-Icon,
der immer den niedrigsten Stand anzeigt.
Man hat mehr Batterien, als man denkt.
Man hat Batterie-Stand vom Garmin.
Man hat Batterie-Stand von der Schaltung.
Man hat Batterie-Stand von der Lampe.
Man hat Batterie-Stand vom Pedal.
Man hat Batterie-Stand vom Rücklicht.
Es wäre mega cool,
aber leider bekommt man die Infos bei Garmin nicht raus.
wenn man die Infos abfragen könnte
und ein Kombiniertes Batterie-Icon machen könnte,
was sobald eines davon niedrig ist,
es einfach anzeigt.
Für ein Icon kannst du nicht anzeigen, von welchem Gerät.
Aber sobald es niedrig ist, kannst du ja durchgucken.
Aber das geht eh nicht,
weil man die Infos nicht aus dem Garmin rausbekommt.
Also ich glaube auch nicht,
dass man Location, was man da abfragen kann,
Position-Info,
GPS-Time-Stamp, Speed.
Kennt ihr irgendeine Web-IP,
wo ich eine Geo-Position übergeben kann
und ich bekomme zurück,
wie schnell man dort fahren darf
oder ob man in einem Ort ist oder nicht.
Mir fällt da keine ein.
Speed-Limit-IP.
Gibt das sowas?
OpenStreetMaps hat sowas? Wirklich?
Okay, Google hat das, aber das kostet halt wieder abfuck.
Hat OpenStreetMaps sowas?
Wäre das Wetter nicht sinnvoll?
Doch, doch, doch.
Es geht jetzt nicht entweder oder.
Man kann das alles machen.
Wetter finde ich persönlich nicht so geil.
Ausführlich Wetter wäre als Icon irgendwie praktisch.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich will es ja nicht übertreiben.
Ich will das haben, was ich benutze und ein bisschen rumspielen.
Wie kriegt man das Speed-Limit von OpenStreetMaps?
Overpass?
Gibt es die Seite?
Guck mal, die Antwort ist von 2013.
Das gibt es wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr, oder?
Overpass-IP.
Tatsächlich? Was ist das denn?
13 Jahre eher nice.
Database-Engine to query OpenStreetMaps-Data.
Okay, das ist natürlich nice, wenn das funktioniert.
Ich curl das mal kurz.
Curl.
Ja, ja, ja.
Moment, was hat er für Schmerzen?
Äh.
Was hat er für Schmerzen jetzt?
That's using XRP?
What?
Ja, okay, nice.
Wie mache ich jetzt eine ordentliche Abfrage da?
Muss man das vielleicht escapen?
Dass Bescht da was komisches macht?
Nee.
Wget. Komm, Wget macht das. Easy.
Wget hat kein Problem damit.
Okay, nice.
Funst.
Okay, das wäre natürlich richtig big brain, Leute.
Man macht einen Web-Request.
Das mache ich aber jetzt nicht.
Man macht einen Web-Request alle,
keine Ahnung, 10 Sekunden oder so.
Da muss derjenige halt sein Handy in Reichweite haben.
Man kann nämlich auch von dem Gerät
einen Web-Request über die App auf dem Handy triggern.
Man macht einen Web-Request alle 15 Sekunden.
Ruft das Speed Limit ab.
Und wenn man über dem Speed Limit ist,
wird es rot.
Eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee.
Fast schon ein bisschen zu advanced.
Aber auf die Idee ist doch schon
irgendjemand anderes gekommen.
Store, Speed Limit.
Ja, siehste?
Dachte ich mir.
Speed Limit.
Ein einfaches Datenfeld, das eine Farbanzeige ...
Geräusche, während es über oder einem bestimmten Tempolimit ...
Ach so.
Marker-Feature.
Ich schreibe das mal auf, weil das Ding ist halt die ...
Ich meine, das ist easy zu machen mit dem Marker.
Mit dem Marker ist easy zu machen.
Aber dann ist es nicht so komfortabel.
Also was man easy machen könnte, ist ...
Knopf drücken.
Dann schickt es einen Web-Request an irgendeinen Server von dir.
Und ...
Mit den Koordinaten.
Dann musstest du es im Endeffekt selbst zusammenfuddeln danach.
Denn ...
Also die Route ...
Also das unterstützt das Garmin-Zeug halt nicht.
Dass du irgendwelche Marker einfügst.
Man müsste das halt irgendwie über einen Umweg machen.
Ich meine, die Koordinaten locken wäre nicht das Problem.
Aber das halt dann ...
Schön zu koordinieren.
Zu kombinieren mit der Map im Anschluss ist dann wahrscheinlich gar nicht so easy.
Wäre interessant, welche AP die da verwenden.
Vermutlich gar keine AP.
Weil die schreiben ja hier ...
Man muss das Tempolimit festlegen im Vorfeld.
Also im Prinzip ist es ...
Unsinnig irgendwie.
Also ...
Wundert mich, dass das noch keiner gebaut hat.
Aber gut, permanente Web-Requests ist wahrscheinlich nicht so geil.
Aber das hier ist doch eigentlich ganz cool, was die hier haben.
Äh ...
Wie kommt man bei ...
War das Minus O?
Ihr wisst doch sowas immer aus dem Kopf.
Wie geht das?
Ach, Minus Groß O ist es nicht.
Keckel Punkt ...
Moment, welchem Ordner bin ich denn hier überhaupt?
TDE Downloads Garmin Pog ...
Keckel Punkt XML ...
Okay, das funktioniert.
Das finde ich mega nice, dass das klappt.
Wir testen mal was, ob das stimmt.
Wir gehen jetzt mal hier hin.
Maps, Google, Frankfurt, Zeil oder so.
Da suchen wir uns jetzt mal die Koordinaten raus.
Oder irgendwo hier, wo man Auto fahren darf.
Und ...
Hallo?
Google, darf ich please markieren?
Ist das möglich?
Leute, eben hat es doch angezeigt, die Koordinaten.
Warum zeigt es jetzt die Koordinaten nicht?
Ach hier, das ist doch ...
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Warum ist das falsch rum?
Ich muss es umgedreht machen, oder?
Ich muss sagen ...
Das ist immer Komma getrennt.
Ich muss sagen, zuerst das ...
Dann das ...
Das soll eine Box werden.
Im Prinzip dann hier eins drauf.
Und da irgendwie noch eins drauf.
Oder auch nicht.
Das ist das falsche Kortsformat.
Das ist einfach nur vertauscht gewesen.
Also das, was ich da gerade abgefragt habe, funktioniert schon mal nett.
Keine Ahnung.
Mit OpenStreetMaps bin ich, was so RP-Sachen angeht,
eh ein bisschen auf dem Kriegsfuß.
Gebt mal die Koordinaten aus dem Beispiel-Link ein.
Geht nicht.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch falsch rum bei denen.
Ja doch, passt doch. Ist richtig.
Aber da kriegt man offensichtlich nichts ...
Kein Tempolimit von Frankfurt.
Aber okay, keine Ahnung.
Das ist auch echt nur Spielerei jetzt.
Was gibt es sonst noch?
Developer hier.
Lost. Nokia. Okay, nice.
Ja okay, da müsste man echt mal schauen,
wie man das Ganze rausbekommt.
Mit einem Reprequest könnte man das Ganze noch machen.
Schön ist es allerdings nicht.
Aber die Idee mit dem Wetter-Icon finde ich ganz gut.
Und dass man einen festgelegten Speed machen kann,
wo man dann sagt,
irgendwie über 40 Orange, über 45, finde ich gut.
Ja, ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Leute, ich kann echt schlecht tippen mit dem Finger.
Glücklicherweise.
Und die Idee mit der Eisbahn finde ich auch sehr, sehr pock.
Muss nur mal gucken,
wie man das am besten einbaut.
Weil so ein komplettes Feld
ist natürlich schon ein bisschen übertrieben.
Vielleicht,
vielleicht, das ist nur mal so eine Idee,
vielleicht könnte ich auch irgendwie noch ein Icon,
so eine Art Tray-Icon-Sache,
dass man irgendwie noch 3 extra Icons anzeigen lassen kann.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Muss ich mir was überlegen.
Aber da fällt mir echt gerade nichts ein.
Ich habe Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Heute war nicht so viel Burger-Stelz.
Irgendwie war heute der mega Side-Track-Stream schlechthin dran.
Side-Track so hoch 10.
Wir haben 2 Stunden Side-Getrackt
und jetzt 1,50 Minuten ein bisschen was gebastelt.
Pock-Verteilung.
Lohnt sich das überhaupt zu committen?
Ja, warum nicht?
Git-Commit-M-Keg-Waiting
Dafür warst du umso produktiver nebenbei.
Das ist doch extrem.
Git-Push.
Was habe ich denn hier?
Git-Push-Origin-Keckel.
Alles klar.
Oh, habe ich mir HTTP geklont?
Oder was?
Das ist ja richtig PP.
Moment.
Wo ist der Knopf,
um auf SSH umzuschalten?
Ist der weg, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist?
Das ist jetzt aber neu, oder?
Git-Remote-RM-Origin
Git-Remote
Remote-Add-Origin
Ja, so.
Und jetzt muss ich allerdings sagen,
wie sieht das aus? SSH?
Git? Wie sieht das richtig aus?
Oh, das ist ja echt geil.
Oder wie GitHub-Add?
Meine Güte.
Git-Add-GitHub-.com
Warte mal, bin ich auf meinem zweiten Browser noch eingeloggt?
Nein.
Warum machen die sowas denn weg?
Das ist so richtig abfuck von Microsoft.
Einfach so?
Slash Data Champ Garmin, Git kommt wahrscheinlich weg, oder?
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt so stimmt.
Äh, hinten Git. Okay.
Push.
Nice. Hat funktioniert.
Gut.
Äh, Data Champ Garmin ist da.
Vor zwei Minuten.
Gepusht.
Ich bin gerade am Einrichten eines CDNs für Images.
Krass, wie viele Standorte hast du so?
Die auf einer Webseite eingebettet sind.
Wie lange dauert es denn üblicherweise, bis Requests tatsächlich gecached werden?
Ich hab nur Onc... Hä?
Das kommt drauf an, was du eingestellt hast.
Ei, mein Kabel fuckt mich ab wieder.
Was ist das hier?
Moment, Moment. Ah, okay. Nee, ich glaub, jetzt geht's so.
Oh, stimmt! Ich mach das jetzt.
Ja, ja, ich guck gleich. Ich hab mich ganz vergessen.
Ich sag doch, erinnere mich dran, wenn ich's vergesse.
Ich wusste, dass ich das wieder vergesse bis abends.
Also, Images und so, das ist nach dem ersten Request gecached.
Also, lokal bei dir.
Ansonsten weiß ich nicht genau, was du machst.
Und wie die Architektur aussieht. Keine Ahnung.
Moin, Fips.
Du kommst genau richtig.
Ich geh jetzt was off. Ich geh jetzt off was essen.
Ich geh jetzt was off. Geiler Satz, ey.
Also, ich weiß gar nicht, wie...
Also, nur weil du einen CDN hast, heißt das noch lange nicht,
dass überhaupt dein Browser da hingeht.
Und wenn er da hingeht, dann ruft er immer von dort ab.
Oder wie jetzt? Oder was jetzt? Oder was? Hä?
Habt ihr eine Idee fürs nächste YouTube-Video-Thema?
Also, ich hab eins. Ich hab eins.
Ich wollt mal wieder ein bisschen...
Irgendeine lustige Story erzählen.
Ich hab ja so eine Themenliste, wo Sachen draufstehen.
Ein bisschen was Lustiges wieder mal zur Abwechslung erzählen,
was so die letzten Jahre über passiert ist.
Aber...
Das hat halt nicht so wirklich Substanz.
Das ist immer mal ganz nice.
Habt ihr irgendeine gute Idee für irgendwas bisschen...
Weil ich hab ja schon lange nichts mehr gemacht.
Ich müsste echt mal wieder was machen.
Und ich hab eine riesenlange Themenliste,
aber irgendwie ist mir das grade nicht so nach irgendwas.
Du hast das Wort.
Viel Spaß. Wir haben die ersten zwei Stunden nichts gemacht.
Aber ich hab Hunger, Leute. Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.
Spätestens morgen früh. Denkt dran, morgen früh wieder...
Irgendwie 9 Uhr oder so.
8.30 Uhr, 9 Uhr.
Aufwachen. Morgen früh muss ich erst eine Runde rennen.
Und...
Aber keine neue Rekordrunde oder so.
Ganz normal.
6,2 Kilo. Oder...
Oder, Chat, wenn ich morgen...
Habt ihr was dagegen, wenn ich morgen erst 9.15 Uhr da bin?
Ist mir eigentlich ziemlich wurscht, ob ihr was dagegen...
Aber ich frag trotzdem mal.
Weil...
Dann könnte ich die große Runde rennen.
Die ist mit...
Mit einer Schleife an die 10 Kilometer.
Anstatt 6,2.
Hab ich schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht.
Wäre eigentlich mal wieder an der Zeit.
Stream Zwift.
Zwift rennen kann ich nicht.
Ich hab...
Ich hab nix, wo man da rennen kann mit.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man da überhaupt rennt.
Braucht man irgendein Laufband oder so.
Da hab ich gar keinen Platz für hier.
Im Arbeitszimmer.
GoPro mitnehmen.
Oh ne.
Mit GoPro rennen hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Außerdem werde ich dann eventuell noch geleakt oder so.
Wenn ich da irgendwo rumrenne.
Leakt?
Zieh mir einfach mal eine fette Sonnenbrille.
Auf, auch wenn scheiß Wetter ist.
Dann ist egal, ob ich geleakt werde.
Ist dir jemand, der Wodafone DS Lite anschaut,
und Erfahrung mit Heimserverfreigaben?
Ja, meine Erfahrung ist, kannst du vergessen.
Weil das rein technisch gesehen nicht funktioniert.
Wenn du nut auf Anbieterseite hast,
hast du gelitten.
Dafür kannst du IPv6 ohne Probleme verwenden.
Weil du einen vollwertigen IPv6 Anschluss hast.
Aber das bringt dir nix,
wenn du nicht per IPv6 von außen drankommst.
Also es gibt natürlich Möglichkeiten,
Portweiterleitungen zu machen.
Auch bei DS Lite.
Aber das braucht immer einen Endpunkt
irgendwo im Internet mit einer Public IPv4 Adresse.
Also wenn du dir zum Beispiel
einen günstigen Server mietest,
mit IPv4 Endpunkt,
dann kannst du einen Tunnel bauen
zwischen dir daheim und dem Server.
Und dann einen Port vom Server weiterleiten.
Irgendwo heim.
Weil du ja dann den Verbindungsaufbau
von innen initiierst zu deinem Server.
Und dann der Port weiterleiten. Das geht.
Aber weiterleiten
direkt auf
sagen wir mal
einen Raspberry Pi bei dir daheim,
ist nicht möglich mit DS Lite.
IPv4 wohlgemerkt.
Nur über Umwege mit Sachen im Internet.
Cloudflare oder was auch immer.
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall was im Internet als Endpunkt.
So die Sachen,
die Zeiten von
ich gehe in meinen Router,
stelle Portweiterleitung ein
auf die interne Raspberry Pi IP
Port 8443
oder was auch immer.
Die sind vorbei mit DS Lite.
Es sei denn, IPv6 mit IPv6
funktioniert es dann ohne Probleme.
Aber wen juckt IPv6?
In den meisten Fällen
juckt einen das ja nicht so richtig.
Ihr kennt ja meine Meinung zu
IPv6.
Also, also, nein.
Nicht meine Meinung zu
IPv6, sondern meine Meinung
zu IPv6 Verbreitung
und wie sich das durchsetzen wird.
Aus dem gleichen Netzwerk?
Doch, das ist kein Problem.
Aus dem gleichen Netzwerk geht.
Egal ob IPv6 oder IPv4.
Da musst du
aber auch keine Ports weiterleiten,
denn innerhalb des gleichen Netzwerkes
spielt
weder Portweiterleitung noch Routing
noch sonst was irgendwie eine Rolle.
Da hängen
beide Kisten am gleichen
Switch im gleichen Netz
und dann kannst du einfach auf die
interne IP zugreifen.
Das ist
egal.
Das hat mit DS Lite nichts zu tun.
Aus dem gleichen
Netz über das Internet?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Achso, Moment.
Du meinst,
reden wir mal
in IPv4, weil es einfacher ist.
Du meinst, wenn dein
Server bei dir daheim
192.168.0.1
slash 24
hat und du hast irgendwo
bei einem Freund auch jemand, der einen Rechner
hat in diesem Netz und dann
übers Internet, weil das das gleiche Netz ist
oder wie? Ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Da ist ja das Internet dazwischen.
Und beides sind interne
Internets und bei IPv6
bei IPv6 kannst du halt
jedem Toaster eine Public IP geben,
die geroutet wird,
aber dann musst du immer noch, also im gleichen
Netz sind die dann trotzdem nicht.
Aber ja, also im gleichen
Netz funktioniert prinzipiell immer, weil da nie
geroutet wird. Aber sobald du routen
müsstest, weil irgendwas dazwischen
ist, dann geht das nicht.
Mir ist nicht ganz klar,
wie es ausschaut bei dir,
dass du denkst,
es müsste funktionieren.
Es schließt sich mir jetzt noch gar nicht.
Also wenn du ein Handy hast
mit IPv6 Adresse
und du hast ein Raspberry Pi
mit IPv6 Adresse,
dann können die miteinander reden,
sofern nicht irgendeine Firewall das Ganze
blockiert.
Also wir reden jetzt nicht von irgendeiner
Link-Local Adresse oder sonst was.
Ähm, ja.
Ja, also das ist wahrscheinlich das Einfachste,
wenn du wirklich Ports weiterleiten willst.
Also meine
Lösung für
Port-Weiterleitung,
wenn es kurz, wenn es
simpel und schnell
funktionieren soll,
ist folgendes, also gehen wir mal von einem DS-Lite
Anschluss aus, wäre folgendes.
Ich miete mir einen
ganz, ganz billigen Server,
sagen wir mal einen 1€-Server
bei IONOS für
1€ im Monat.
Dann mache ich den SSH-Tunnel auf
genau, mache ich den SSH-Tunnel
minus G
und leite den Port weiter. Also ich würde
dann sowas hier in der Richtung machen wie,
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich das aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege.
SSH
minus
G
R
dann sagen wir 8443
weitergeleitet auf
192.168
hier irgendwie 0.1
Port
ja 443
und dann
max at
mein Server
0w.d
So und ich glaube,
das müsste dann funktionieren, wenn ich das jetzt richtig
aus dem Kopf...
Ja das stimmt, das geht nur für TCP-Traffic.
Ja das ist richtig. So was das jetzt
macht, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe,
bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher,
das macht ein Port, also
das loggt sich remote auf diesem Server
ein, öffnet
dort Port 8443
also
0.0.0.0
8443, also global,
also halt nicht nur
an Localhost gebunden,
macht das Port 8443 für
alle auf und alles, was in diesen Port geht,
wird über den Tunnel geschickt und am Tunnel
Endpunkt weitergeleitet
an diese lokale IP diesen Port.
So ich glaube, das ist richtig.
Das wäre für mich die simpelste Variante für
eine Port-Weiterleitung, wenn ich
sowas mal zackig umgehen müsste
und es sich um TCP-Traffic handelt.
Was man natürlich auch machen kann ist,
intern dann
einen WireGuard oder OpenVPN
Server haben, auf den man weiterleitet
den Port.
Also damit es klappt, muss der...
Damit es klappt, muss
Client und Server auf gleichem Protokoll sein.
Ja?
Das ist prinzipiell erstmal
so pauschal gesagt korrekt.
Natürlich gibt es Varianten
das zu umgehen, aber in der Regel
ist das so, ja.
Aber da ich doch von meinem Heimrechner
aus zugreife, bin ich doch
über die gleiche IPv6 Adresse unterwegs
oder bin ich drum... Ach!
Jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst.
Willst du denn
auf die IPv6 Adresse
von deinem Router zugreifen
oder auf die IPv6 Adresse von deinem
Raspberry Pi?
Also wenn du auf die IPadresse von deinem
Raspberry Pi zugreifen möchtest,
dann sollte das funktionieren,
sofern, sofern
das Netzwerkgerät dazwischen
nicht irgendwas blockt.
Alternativ kannst du auch einfach
nicht die...
Nicht diese...
Oh! IPv6 Leute, da bin ich der übelste
Kacknub. Alternativ kannst du auch
um lokal drauf zuzugreifen, nicht die...
Wie heißt denn das?
Die eigentliche IPv6
Adresse nehmen, sondern die local IPv6
Adresse. Ist es bei IPv6
nicht so, dass du standardmäßig
mehrere Adressen bekommst?
Ne local... Also so ne link
local randomized Adresse
und ne... Ach ich hab
keine Ahnung von IPv6 man.
Ähm...
Du kriegst glaube ich ne automatische IPv6
Adresse, die quasi
für alle
quasi in diesem
Netzwerk
an diesem Port per Switch
irgendwie gelten und du kriegst
noch eine, die routbar ist.
Och kein Schimmer
man, ich hab keine Ahnung davon.
Ich hab deutlich zu wenig mit IPv6
gemacht. Aber prinzipiell
geht das, was du hier schreibst.
Also du kannst...
Dein Heimrechner hat auf jeden Fall nicht die gleiche
IPv6 Adresse.
Weil entweder kriegt dein
Raspberry Pi eine eigene IPv6 Adresse
und dein Rechner eine eigene IPv6 Adresse.
Dann können die ohne Probleme miteinander
reden.
Sofern das Netzwerkgerät dazwischen
nichts blockt. Sollten sie
im gleichen Netz sein, haben beide Geräte
trotzdem unterschiedliche IPadressen, können
aber direkt miteinander reden, weil link
local IPv6 Adresse.
Mh...
Möchtest du sowas wie
App-Weiterleitung machen, also nämlich die
IP deines Routers
nehmen und quasi weiterleiten
auf die
interne IPv6 Adresse
von deinem Raspberry Pi auf einem speziellen
Port, hab ich keine Ahnung wie man das
konfiguriert, aber müsste theoretisch auch gehen.
Aber dann hat trotzdem dein Heimrechner
eine andere IP.
Ich hab kein Schimmer
wie es genau ist bei IPv6.
Ok, drei
Stück kriegt man. Link local, global,
und Internet.
Bisschen was ist doch noch hängen geblieben.
Aber
zu wenig Plan.
Also du kannst auf jeden Fall
wenn ihr am gleichen Switch hängen
kriegt
und ich geh mal
davon aus, dass diese zwei Sachen am gleichen Switch
hängen bei dir, dann müsste dein
Heimrechner und dein Raspberry Pi
eine IPv6 Link local Adresse
bekommen haben. Woran erkennt man
eine Link local Adresse, Leute?
Ähm, die haben doch
so ein spezielles Format.
Ja, FE80, genau.
Also sowohl dein Rechner
als auch dein Raspberry Pi,
die müssten so eine FE80 Adresse
bekommen haben.
Nachdem du den Port hochgefahren hast.
So, und mit dieser FE80
Adresse kannst du
zwischen den zwei Kisten, wenn die am gleichen
Switch hängen, kommunizieren miteinander.
Und es ist nicht die Public IPv6
Adresse von dir, sondern die Link
Warum kann ich das nicht copy...
Ey! Was ist das?
Copy ist ausgekraut. What the fuck?
Jetzt geht's wieder. Okay, was auch immer.
Ja, jetzt meine ich ja alle
Geräte, die am gleichen Switch hängen.
Da funktioniert das.
Also zwischen zwei Geräten
direkt, also wenn die am Switch hängen geht's ja auch.
Da merkt der IPv6 nichts von.
Oder? Ich wüsste zwar nicht
wie, aber sicher bin ich mir
bei IPv6 prinzipiell nicht.
Also du müsstest
so eine FE80 Adresse bekommen haben.
Sowohl beim Raspberry Pi als auch auf deinem Rechner.
Und da kannst du zwischen kommunizieren.
Direkt.
Zwischen den zwei Kisten.
Hat denn
die Kiste
auf die dein...
Also, der Raspberry Pi,
auf dem dein Nextcloud läuft,
hat der denn eine IPv6
oder eine IPv4 Adresse?
Beides. Okay.
Dann müsstest du aber, und hängt der
Raspberry Pi und der Rechner, von dem du
darauf zugreifen willst, am gleichen Switch
oder halt an der gleichen Fritzbox.
Ja.
Dann solltest du zumindest,
wenn du mal hier
ipadd oder
ifconfig machst, solltest du
zumindest von deinem, achso ja, und dein
Rechner braucht auch eine IPv6 Adresse,
solltest du zumindest mit der link.local
FE80 Adresse drauf zugreifen können.
Du willst DNS machen,
heißt im Endeffekt,
wenn du
DNS mit dünnDNS
und gedönst machen willst, das bedeutet
ja im Endeffekt dann, dass
die public IPv6 Adresse
von deinem Router
aufgelöst wird,
also dass dein
DNS-Name aufgelöst wird zu der
public IP von deinem Router.
Das heißt, du brauchst auf jeden Fall, wenn du willst,
dass das geht,
eine
IPv6-Anleitung.
Trotzdem, oder? Oder?
Nee, brauchst du nicht, weil es gibt kein NAT.
Wie macht man das?
Wie macht man das eigentlich?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Gar nicht machst du das, ne?
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Weil IPv6, standardmäßig kein NAT,
dementsprechend auch kein Port-Forwarding.
Heißt im Endeffekt,
du brauchst eine public IPv6 Adresse
auf deinem Raspberry Pi
und machst dann in deiner Router-Firewall
einen Port frei und machst
einen statischen DNS-Eintrag
auf die IPv6-Adresse
von deinem Raspberry Pi.
Aber das alleine bringt es dir ja nicht.
Wenn die IPv6
dynamisch ist von der Fritzbox
und das dahinter
nicht geruht, wie ist denn das
überhaupt?
Wie funktioniert denn das bei einer Fritzbox und IPv6?
Bekommen die Geräte
dahinter eine public
geruhtbare IPv6-Adresse
oder
machen die da irgendwelche
NAT-IPv6-Geschichten?
Du kannst ja entweder...
Dann geht auch Port-Weiterleitung.
Wenn Port-Weiterleitung nicht geht,
dann ist da eine Firewall dazwischen,
aber die Endgeräte kriegen public IPs.
Wenn es public IPs sind,
dann
müsste erstmal die Firewall
freigeschaltet werden auf dem Port
und der DNS
müsste die IP vom Raspberry Pi auflösen,
also nicht die public IP von der Fritzbox.
Ich sag euch Leute, da sieht man wieder dran,
wenn man nur an IPv4
gewöhnt ist,
das ist ganz schön Umdenken angesagt bei IPv6.
Also ich denke,
es gibt zwei Varianten.
Entweder hat dein
Raspberry Pi,
bekommt das eine gültige
IPv6-Adresse, die
routbar ist im Internet,
dann kannst du es mit dünnem DNS
vergessen, dann müsste dein
Raspberry Pi dünnen DNS machen
und seine
IPv6-Adresse quasi
announcen an den dünnen DNS
und nicht die
Fritzbox-IP,
weil die Fritzbox-IP ist die Fritzbox-IP
und da kommt man nicht bei deiner Nextcloud raus.
Also wenn das der Fall
ist, müsste ein dünnen DNS-Client
auf den Raspberry Pi drauf
und der Raspberry Pi
würde dann regelmäßig
seine public routbare
IPv6-Adresse hinterlegen
unter diesem DNS-Namen,
dann müsstest du in deiner Fritzbox die
Firewall freigeben, dass
es erlaubt ist, vom Internet
zuzugreifen auf
die IP deines Raspberry Pis,
nicht die Link-Local,
die public routbare IPv6-Adresse
des Raspberry Pis, müsstest du in der
Fritzbox Firewall freigeben, sagen wir
Port 443,
das würde funktionieren,
machen die IPv6
auf der Fritzbox, wo ich keine Ahnung hab,
ob die das machen, dann müsste es mit
Portweiterleitung und dünnen DNS trotzdem funktionieren.
Wisst ihr, was die machen?
Wie ist denn das?
Wahrscheinlich machen die IPv6
NAT oder so eklige Geschichten.
Ja, ist echt nicht so ohne.
Ach guck mal, hier gibt's
das hat ja jetzt mit IPv6
nichts zu...
Ist das eine Firewall-Freischaltung in Fritzbox-Logik?
Ja, da müsste man das
wahrscheinlich da machen, irgendwo.
Wenn das statisch ist, dann kannst du auch
einen statischen DNS setzen, ja.
Aber die meisten Leute haben ja keine
Public Domain, wo sie einen statischen DNS setzen können.
Das heißt, du kannst über einen dünnen
DNS-Dienst ja auch eine
statische IP setzen,
indem du immer die gleiche IP announce.
Der Slide
ist doppeltes NAT, nur bei
IPv4 doppeltes NAT.
Wir müssen erst mal
rauskriegen, wie das ist.
Es ist eigentlich ganz easy rauszukriegen.
Schau nach, was für IP-Adressen dein Raspberry Pi hat.
Dein Raspberry Pi
sollte
mindestens mal
eine IPv6
doch, gibt's auch
Dein Raspberry Pi sollte eine interne
IPv4-Adresse haben, wahrscheinlich.
Eine link-local
IPv6-Adresse, also eine, die mit
fe80 anfängt. Und wenn
dein Raspberry Pi zusätzlich noch
noch eine andere
IPv6-Adresse hat,
diese fe80, dann hat er wahrscheinlich
eine Public-IP. Guck dir mal an,
was dein Raspberry Pi alles für IPs hat.
Und hat er noch mehr, als
die fe80? Probier's mal mit
IP-Add anstatt mit
ifconfig, falls du ifconfig nimmst.
IP-Add zeigt manchmal mehr an.
Ja, noch
zwei weitere. Das ist gut.
Dann hast du wahrscheinlich eine Public-IP
v6-Adresse.
Denke ich.
Ohne es zu wissen,
ehrlich gesagt. Chat,
habt ihr eine Ahnung, woran man eine Public-IP
v6-Adresse erkennen kann?
Wahrscheinlich einfach, dass sie nicht fe80
ist, oder? Okay, die
Fritzbox kann entweder unique local
v6 verteilen.
Okay, unique local
bedeutet, du kriegst
eine lokale IPv6-Adresse, die aber
nicht ins Internet geroutet wird.
Oder eine global unique
v6 im internen Netz. Aha.
Also
global unique ist der Default?
Das heißt,
standardmäßig müsste sein Raspberry Pi
eine internetroutbare IPv6
haben? Oder wie ist das?
Ja. Okay, fängt mit
2001 an.
Kannst du uns mal die Anfänge
deiner IPv6-Adressen posten?
Vielleicht haben wir ja irgendwelche
high-IQ-Chat-Leute. Ich finde das Thema nämlich
gerade, ich wollte eigentlich schon vor 17 Minuten
was fordern gehen, recht spannend.
Kannst du uns die Anfänge von deinen IPv6-Adressen
posten? Damit gibt es ja genug
Möglichkeiten, damit leakst du ja nichts.
Und dann
weiß der Chat ja vielleicht
was es ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich reibe mir
das gerade so. Okay, fe80 weiß
ich. Fe80 ist link-local.
Okay,
2fd00. Okay.
Wir googeln jetzt mal.
Kennzeichnet lokal generierte IP-Adresse.
Okay.
Kennzeichnet lokal generiert. Okay, damit kommst
du schon mal nicht ins Internet.
Und dann hast du
IPv6.
Ist das public?
Ah!
Das hier ist deine public. Okay.
Setzt du mal.
Die brauchst du.
Probier doch mal aus,
probier
doch mal aus, die
N-Map schon offen.
Oh ja, hier drauf, oder wie?
Ja, beste Idee.
Ist
address types.
Äh.
Aber ich dachte, die anderen fangen mit
mit 2001 an.
Ach so, das ist das, was die Fritzbox
erkennt. Alter,
meine Güte, das ist so krass kompliziert.
Äh, gestern im Stream
gab es Stellenbeschreibung.
So erhalte ich zwei Adressen auf dem Subnet?
Das ist irgend so ein
Vodafone-Ding, oder?
Mach dir keine Gedanken.
Ich hab, du siehst, ich blick's auch nicht.
IPv6 ist so ein Ding, da hast du nicht viele, die da durchblicken.
Aber anscheinend ist das
irgendein Vodafone-Ding.
Also ich
vermute mal, ich vermute folgendes.
Du kannst diese,
also was auf jeden Fall gehen müsste ist,
wenn du auf die
FE80-Adresse gehst von deinem Rechner aus.
Das ist Link-Log,
das müsste funktionieren, solange Nextcloud
darauf listen.
Das kannst du ja mal ausprobieren.
Wenn du auf die FE80-Adresse gehst,
Port 80, Port 443, was auch immer da
Nextcloud läuft, das müsste auf jeden Fall funktionieren.
Ähm, diese
2A02,
das ist anscheinend was aus dem
Prefix von Vodafone.
Und da bräuchte man wahrscheinlich
eine
Firewall-Freischaltung
in der Fritzbox.
Dass das funktioniert.
Das würde ich als nächstes probieren
dann. Und dann würde ich
den DNS-Eintrag machen.
So. Aber mehr
können wir jetzt echt nicht machen, weil
wir kommen ja nicht dran.
Wie gesagt, gestern war das mit Stellenanzeigen.
So, und jetzt muss ich echt was essen, Leute.
Wir sehen uns und hören uns. Ne, wir sehen uns nicht.
Wir hören uns nur. Bis denn, macht's gut, Leute.
See you.